Hello, and welcome to your second drink of Back From Vacation. This is the episode that sees Michael returning from his vacation with Jan in Jamaica. Tan everywhere. Jan everywhere. Well, when we first broke down this episode, we mentioned that there were a number of deleted scenes and, you know, some of them are added back into those superfan versions. For example, there's a whole runner of Michael at the airport getting his bags, losing a bag, driving into work, and we got a letter about them.
你好，欢迎收听《办公室》重温播客的第二期节目。这一集讲述了迈克尔和简从牙买加度假归来。到处都是晒黑的痕迹。到处都是简。嗯，当我们最初拆解这一集时，我们提到过有很多删减片段，而且，你知道，其中一些被加回了“超级粉丝版”中。例如，有一整段迈克尔在机场取行李、丢行李、开车上班的戏份，我们还收到了一封关于这些片段的信。
Courtney Ann wrote in and said, "'You forgot to mention in the driving scene with Michael, talking about the chill pill, he drives past a sign that says Dayton Rogers of California. It's a sign that they were clearly filming in California and not Pennsylvania. Yes, Courtney Ann, I watched the Peacock super fan of this one and these scenes are very funny.
考特尼·安写信来说：“你们忘了提到迈克尔开车的那场戏，他在谈论‘冷静药丸’时，开车经过了一个写着‘加州代顿·罗杰斯’的标志。这显然说明他们是在加州拍摄的，而不是在宾夕法尼亚州。是的，考特尼·安，我看了Peacock的超级粉丝版，这些场景非常有趣。”
Angela, you described them in our breakdown. And I saw the sign that Courtney is talking about. We tried so hard not to show those kinds of things. Yes, and I'm sure that this sequence got cut for time, but I also have to wonder if this sign is one of the reasons, because otherwise they probably would have had to pay to remove that in post. They would paint out the palm trees, they would paint out California references on our driving shots. I kind of wish it said Dave Rogers of California
安吉拉，你在我们的拆解中描述过它们。我看到了考特尼提到的那个标志。我们非常努力地不去展示这类东西。是的，我相信这段戏是因为时长原因被剪掉的，但我也不禁怀疑这个标志是不是原因之一，因为否则他们可能得花钱在后期制作中把它抹掉。他们会把棕榈树抹掉，把开车镜头中关于加州的参考抹掉。我真希望上面写的是“加州戴夫·罗杰斯”。
and it was an Easter egg. Well, I can't believe they shot in an airport baggage claim. And they did a whole driving sequence. That's a lot of budget. That's a lot of money right there. And then they all got cut. Yeah. I need to mention another nugget from the Peacock superfan episode. I just loved it. OK, so you know the scene where Michael is in his office and he's playing hot, hot, hot, hot Pam over and over again. Well, right before that, he has a talking head
那会是一个彩蛋。天哪，我不敢相信他们在机场行李提取处拍了戏。他们还拍了整整一段开车戏。那得花多少预算啊。那得花多少钱。结果全被剪掉了。是的。我得提一下Peacock超级粉丝版里的另一个小彩蛋。我太喜欢了。好吧，你知道迈克尔在办公室里一遍又一遍地播放《Feeling Hot, Hot, Hot》那场戏吗？就在那之前，他有一个采访镜头，
that would have led into that scene that they added back to the super fan episode. You have to hear it. I did a little scuba diving at Sandals, Jamaica, and I learned about a thing called decompression, which means if you're underwater and you rise too quickly, you can die. It didn't apply to me because I was in the shallow end of the pool, but coming back here,
本来会引出那场戏，但被加回了超级粉丝版。你一定要听听。“我在牙买加的桑德尔斯度假村潜水时，学到了一种叫‘减压’的东西，意思是如果你在水下上升太快，可能会死。这对我没影响，因为我是在泳池浅水区，但回到这里，
it does apply. I can't just start my job up immediately. I need time to decompress or I will die. Feeling hot, hot, hot. Feeling hot, hot, hot. Feeling hot, hot, hot. So that's what he's doing. He's decompressing. He's easing himself back into the workday. Yes.
它确实有影响。我不能立刻开始工作。我需要时间减压，否则我会死。”“Feeling hot, hot, hot. Feeling hot, hot, hot. Feeling hot, hot, hot.”所以他就是在做这个。他在减压。他在让自己慢慢适应工作日。是的。
Yeah. Well, next up we got a letter from Christine W. She says, at 12 minutes, 11 seconds, is Michael sitting in his office holding a bottle of chocolate sauce? Okay, Christine, first of all, I need to say you have the vision of a hawk. I mean, this is like blink and you miss it. Yes, he is sitting in his office
嗯，接下来我们收到了一封克里斯汀·W的信。她说，在12分11秒，迈克尔是不是坐在办公室里拿着一瓶巧克力酱？好吧，克里斯汀，首先，我得说你的视力简直像鹰一样。我的意思是，这简直是眨眼就错过的镜头。是的，他坐在办公室里，
holding what looks like a bottle of chocolate sauce, and then Dwight bursts through the shades to tell him he needs to come to the warehouse. I did not clock the chocolate sauce. You wouldn't see it. It's like, I watched it several times after we got this letter. It's so quick, but also it's not chocolate sauce.
手里拿着看起来像一瓶巧克力酱的东西，然后德怀特冲过百叶窗告诉他必须去仓库。我没注意到那个巧克力酱。你肯定看不见。我收到这封信后看了好几遍。它太快了，而且那根本不是巧克力酱。
What is it? It is a bottle of tanning lotion. So here's what's going on. Michael is really stressed out because, you know, this photo of Jan on the beach has gone all over the place. Yeah. Well, in the super fan episode, there is a scene of Michael sitting in his office, sniffing
那是什么？那是一瓶美黑乳液。事情是这样的。迈克尔非常紧张，因为你知道，那张简在海滩上的照片已经传得到处都是了。是的。在超级粉丝版里，有一个场景是迈克尔坐在办公室里，闻着
this bottle of tanning lotion. He's taking like deep breaths. And then he has a talking head where he explains that his sense of smell is most important to him and that he's sniffing the tanning lotion because the smell is taking him back to the relaxed feeling of his vacation. But in the episode that aired, you just see him sitting there holding it and then Dwight burst through the window.
这瓶美黑乳液。他深呼吸了好几次。然后他有一个采访镜头，解释说嗅觉对他来说最重要，他闻美黑乳液是因为那种味道让他回想起度假时放松的感觉。但在播出的版本中，你只看到他坐在那儿拿着它，然后德怀特就冲过窗户了。
You don't see the whole- You don't know any of the backstory. No, none of it. Well, you know in this episode, the party planning committee is tasked with throwing a luau in the warehouse and they're serving spam. So in our breakdown, we got into this whole discussion about spam and we got some mail. Kristen Oh said, FYI, you guys are cutting up spam because it is a popular thing to eat in Hawaii and you're preparing a luau.
你没看到整个过程——你不知道任何背景故事。不，一点都不知道。嗯，你知道在这一集里，派对策划委员会的任务是在仓库举办一场卢奥派对，他们供应午餐肉。所以在我们的拆解中，我们讨论了午餐肉，还收到了一些邮件。克里斯汀·奥说，顺便告诉你们，你们切午餐肉是因为它是夏威夷流行的食物，而你们正在准备卢奥派对。
As Meta said, spam is short for spiced ham. Yes. I didn't know it was short for spiced ham. I didn't either. We got so much mail about Spam after this episode aired. And in our episode 64, Revisited with Randall Einhorn, I shared a letter that we received from two sisters, Laura and Amanda, with a whole bunch of fast facts about Spam.
正如梅塔所说，Spam是“Spiced Ham”（香料火腿）的缩写。是的。我以前不知道它是香料火腿的缩写。我也不知道。这一集播出后，我们收到了很多关于午餐肉的邮件。在我们的第64集《与兰德尔·艾因霍恩重温》中，我分享了一封我们从劳拉和阿曼达姐妹那里收到的信，里面有一大堆关于午餐肉的冷知识。
Yeah, it was so great. We learned about Spam's connection to Hawaii. We learned there is a spam museum in Minnesota. Mm hmm. Laura and Amanda sent us some spam merch. I have a spam hat. I have spam socks. Thank you, ladies. Well, speaking of I had some spam fried rice in Hawaii earlier this year and it was so good. Like so good. That sounds wonderful. It was one of our favorite things that we ate during our Hawaii vacation was on the very first night,
是的，太棒了。我们了解了午餐肉与夏威夷的渊源。我们还知道明尼苏达州有一个午餐肉博物馆。嗯哼。劳拉和阿曼达寄给我们一些午餐肉周边。我有一个午餐肉帽子。我还有午餐肉袜子。谢谢你们，女士们。说到这个，我今年早些时候在夏威夷吃过午餐肉炒饭，非常好吃。真的很好吃。听起来太棒了。那是我们在夏威夷度假期间最喜欢吃的食物之一，就在第一天晚上，
we ordered this spam fried rice. Do you know how to make it? No, but I kind of want to figure it out. Yeah. Because it was like a crowd pleaser. The crowd being my family. Well, you'll have one more at the table if you make it. Okay.
我们点了这个午餐肉炒饭。你知道怎么做吗？不知道，但我有点想研究一下。是的。因为它很受欢迎。受欢迎的对象就是我的家人。好吧，如果你做了，桌上会多一个人吃的。好的。
Well, listen, that's all we got. Please enjoy this breakdown of Back from Vacation. Feeling hot, hot, hot. I'm Jenna Fischer. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you.
好了，听着，这就是我们所有的内容了。请享受这次对《度假归来》的拆解。Feeling hot, hot, hot. 我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你进行终极《办公室》重温播客。
Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies. Hi lady, how's it going? It's going really great. I'm in my new podcast closet. I moved from one closet to another closet, but this is my permanent podcast closet. It's for podcasting. This is the third closet I've seen you in podcasting. That's right, because I did casino night from my daughter's closet.
每周我们都会拆解一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士。嗨，女士，最近怎么样？非常好。我在我的新播客衣橱里。我从一个衣橱搬到了另一个衣橱，但这是我永久的播客衣橱。它是专门用来录播客的。这是我见过的你录播客的第三个衣橱了。没错，因为我是在我女儿的衣橱里录的“赌场之夜”。
Well, let's tell everyone what we're here to talk about today. We're talking about the episode Back from Vacation. It is season three, episode 11, written by Justin Spitzer and directed by Julian Farino. Let's hear a summary. All right, well, in this episode, Michael returns from his all-inclusive trip to Jamaica. He is tan.
好了，告诉大家我们今天要聊什么。我们聊的是《度假归来》这一集。这是第三季第11集，由贾斯汀·斯皮策编剧，朱利安·法里诺执导。让我们听听剧情摘要。好的，在这一集中，迈克尔从他牙买加的全包式旅行中归来。他晒黑了。
He is happy. We find out who he went with. Mm-hmm. Yes, we do. Jan. Scandalous office romance. Well, despite Jan's insistence that Michael keep Yes, we do. Jan. Scandalous. Office. Romance. Well, despite Jan's insistence that Michael keep their vacation a secret, Michael accidentally
他很开心。我们发现了他是和谁一起去的。嗯哼。是的，我们发现了。简。办公室的丑闻恋情。嗯，尽管简坚持要迈克尔保守秘密，但迈克尔不小心
circulates an intimate photo of them to the entire office and beyond. So he and Dwight are going to spend this episode trying to retrieve and delete the photo while Michael awaits Jan's arrival in Scranton. Meanwhile, Angela has to throw together a last minute luau, and Pam gives Jim advice that helps his relationship with Karen. Hmm. Yeah.
把一张他们亲密的照片传给了整个办公室甚至更多人。所以他和德怀特这一集都要忙着找回并删除这张照片，同时迈克尔在斯克兰顿等待简的到来。与此同时，安吉拉必须临时凑出一个卢奥派对，而帕姆给了吉姆一些建议，帮助了他和凯伦的关系。嗯。是的。
Let's jump into Fast Fact number one. This episode was written by Justin Spitzer. Now, we talked a little bit about Justin before. He created the show Superstore. And remember, we found out that he's the person that wrote the twin absorption line for Dwight in grief counseling. Yes, that was the Jen Salata deep dive. And we found that out. Well, this was Justin's first full episode. So I reached out to him because I've kept in touch with Justin since we wrapped.
让我们进入第一个冷知识。这一集是由贾斯汀·斯皮策编剧的。我们之前聊过一点贾斯汀。他创作了《超级商店》。还记得吗，我们发现他是那个为《悲伤辅导》中德怀特写下“双胞胎吸收”台词的人。是的，那是珍·萨拉塔的深度挖掘。我们发现了这一点。嗯，这是贾斯汀的第一部完整剧本。所以我联系了他，因为我们结束拍摄后一直保持联系。
Justin's just one of my favorite people, I have to say. He is so lovely. So I reached out to Justin and I asked him, where did the idea for this episode come from? And he said it was really simple. Greg really wanted to explore this idea of that feeling you get when you have to come back from your vacation and go back to your work grind. And that was it. That was, they built the whole story around that one theme. You know what I love about that is that I find the stories I like the most have such a simple premise. They're not heavy on premise, and I find them usually the most relatable.
贾斯汀是我最喜欢的人之一，我必须说。他太可爱了。所以我联系了贾斯汀，问他这一集的灵感来自哪里。他说很简单。格雷格真的很想探索那种度假归来后必须回到工作苦差事中的感觉。就是这样。他们围绕这个主题构建了整个故事。你知道我喜欢这一点的原因吗？因为我发现我最喜欢的故事都有一个简单的前提。它们的前提并不沉重，而且我发现它们通常最能引起共鸣。
Same, same. I feel like that's what made Halloween so great. You have to fire someone on Halloween. Yeah. That's it. That's it. That's it. You've just had a great vacation
一样，一样。我觉得这就是《万圣节》那么棒的原因。你必须在万圣节解雇某人。是的。就是这样。就是这样。你刚度过了一个很棒的假期，
and now you're faced with the reality of your life back home. Yes. So then I asked Justin, what was it like being your first full script? And he said he was incredibly nervous about doing a good job. And he remembers that it was normal for writers to get a full week to write their first draft. You would usually get sent off on a Friday,
现在你必须面对回到家后的生活现实。是的。所以我问贾斯汀，作为你的第一个完整剧本感觉如何？他说他非常紧张，想做好工作。他记得编剧通常有一整周的时间来写初稿。你通常会在周五被派发任务，
and you would have the whole next week, and it wouldn't be due until the following Monday. You'd get about nine days. So he said that this script though, they did not finish breaking it until Monday night pretty late and Greg said I'm gonna need this Friday morning. Ah! So he only had three days. This is reminding me of when Gene and Lee had to do their first script in like three days. Yeah, or the time Steve had to write his script over a weekend with his in-laws visiting. Yes, exactly, exactly.
然后你有接下来的一整周，直到下周一才截止。你大约有九天时间。但他说这个剧本，他们直到周一晚上很晚才拆解完，格雷格说我周五早上就要。啊！所以他只有三天时间。这让我想起吉恩和李第一次写剧本时也只有三天左右。是的，或者史蒂夫有一次在岳父母来访时不得不利用周末写剧本。是的，完全正确，完全正确。
Justin said he grabbed a case of Diet Coke out of the kitchen. He said he basically lived on that for the next 72 hours. Oh, gosh. And I guess apparently after Justin left to go write the script, because you could write your scripts at home, one of the other writers said to Greg, we're not behind. Why does he have to write it so fast? And that Greg smiled and said,
贾斯汀说他从厨房拿了一箱健怡可乐。他说接下来的72小时他基本就是靠那个活着的。哦，天哪。而且我猜显然在贾斯汀离开去写剧本后，因为你可以在家写剧本，另一位编剧对格雷格说，我们并没有落后。为什么他必须写得这么快？格雷格微笑着说，
to keep the pressure up, just tighten in the screws. Oh, Greg! And he said, just tighten in the screws. Oh, Greg! And he said, I think in retrospect, it weirdly did relieve some of the pressure of it being the very first script that he was writing, because no one really expects a script that you write in only three days to be very good. So he was like, well, this is what it is. He did a dad mind trick.
为了保持压力，拧紧螺丝。哦，格雷格！他说，回想起来，这奇怪地减轻了一些作为他写的第一个剧本的压力，因为没人真的指望你三天写出来的剧本会很好。所以他想，好吧，就是这样。他玩了个心理战。
Oh my gosh. He was like, yeah, this is what it is. He did a dad mind trick. Oh my gosh. He was like, yeah, I need it in three days. But also knowing that that way, Justin wouldn't make it too precious and take too long with it and kind of just shake off the cobwebs and jump in the deep end. How many analogies can I use? It was good.
哦，天哪。他就像是，是的，就是这样。他玩了个心理战。哦，天哪。他就像是，是的，我三天内需要它。但也知道这样一来，贾斯汀就不会太纠结，不会花太长时间，而是会抖掉懒散，直接跳进深水区。我能用多少个比喻？这很好。
I liked them. Well, Justin said he wants everyone to know that what we ended up shooting was way, way better than what he originally wrote, that he brought that script back. And he said he was not able to write the script that you see on the screen in three days. It went through a bunch of rewrites. And basically, he said, if I showed you my first draft, your reaction would be Yeah, that pretty much seems like
我喜欢它们。嗯，贾斯汀说他想让大家知道，我们最终拍摄的内容比他最初写的要好得多，他把那个剧本带回来了。他说他无法在三天内写出你在屏幕上看到的那个剧本。它经过了很多次重写。基本上，他说，如果我给你们看我的初稿，你们的反应会是“是的，这看起来确实像
something it would take a person three days to write. But anyway, I thought that was so sweet. I love all of that. That's some really great behind the scenes in the writer's room. All right, fast fact number two, Angela, directed by Julian Farino. Julian!
一个人三天能写出来的东西”。但无论如何，我觉得这太可爱了。我喜欢这一切。这真是一些很棒的编剧室幕后故事。好了，第二个冷知识，安吉拉，由朱利安·法里诺执导。朱利安！
Julian was born and raised in London. He attended Cambridge University. We loved him. We loved this British man. Well, Jenna, we were so excited to meet him because he had directed an episode of Rome on HBO. And you and I, at this time, were binging that show together.
朱利安在伦敦出生长大。他毕业于剑桥大学。我们很喜欢他。我们喜欢这个英国男人。嗯，珍娜，我们非常兴奋能见到他，因为他执导过HBO的《罗马》。那时你和我正在一起刷那部剧。
We were really into it. Jenna, I even remember one day when he was on set that we quoted a line to him. We were like, do you remember the line where we were like, 13? 13? Oh, yeah. That was such a good scene. And he looked at us and he was like, okay, okay, ladies. Well, if if you could go back to reception, we're Anyway, you guys, Rome was a show on HBO. And in my opinion, Rome was the first Game of Thrones.
我们真的很入迷。珍娜，我甚至记得有一天他在片场时，我们对他引用了一句台词。我们说，你还记得那句台词吗，我们说“13？13？”哦，是的。那场戏太棒了。他看着我们说，好吧，好吧，女士们。嗯，如果你们能回到接待处，我们……总之，伙计们，《罗马》是HBO的一部剧。在我看来，《罗马》是第一部《权力的游戏》。
It was very Game of Thrones-y, yes. It's extremely violent and bloody. And there's lots of warring political factions. What are you wearing? I'm wearing my Game of Thrones shirt because I don't know. Rome makes me think of Game of Thrones. So today on the podcast, I'm wearing my Game of Thrones shirt. Well, Julian also directed the first three seasons of Entourage,
它非常有《权力的游戏》的感觉，是的。它极其暴力和血腥。而且有很多交战的政治派系。你穿的是什么？我穿着我的《权力的游戏》衬衫，因为我不知道。罗马让我想到了《权力的游戏》。所以今天在播客上，我穿着我的《权力的游戏》衬衫。嗯，朱利安还执导了《明星伙伴》的前三季，
including Rainn Wilson's episode, I Love You Too. Oh, I just think it's very funny because Charles McDougall, our other director, had also directed episodes of Rome. I just think it's really funny that we had these guys who had been directing bloody battles come into our little paper company. But they were so fun. I mean, yeah, that the scale of production that they had to do with chariots tipping over and people flying through the air and
包括雷恩·威尔森的那一集《我也爱你》。哦，我觉得这很有趣，因为查尔斯·麦克杜格尔，我们的另一位导演，也执导过《罗马》的剧集。我觉得很有趣的是，我们有这些曾经执导过血腥战斗的家伙来到我们的小纸业公司。但他们太有趣了。我的意思是，是的，他们必须处理的制作规模，战车翻倒，人们在空中飞，
and then literally it'd be like, hey, can you use the stapler slightly harder next to the copier? Like, the difference in our quote unquote action sequence on Dunder Mifflin versus Rome. Well, I think part of Greg's thinking here was remembering that our show was not just a comedy, that it had dramatic elements, and was about real human people. And so by having some of these directors who are known for doing these dramas, not just a comedy, that it had dramatic elements and was about real human people.
然后字面上会变成，“嘿，你能在使用复印机旁边的订书机时稍微用力一点吗？”就像，我们在《办公室》里的所谓动作戏与《罗马》相比。嗯，我想格雷格在这里的部分想法是记住我们的剧不仅仅是一部喜剧，它有戏剧性的元素，是关于真实的人。所以通过聘请一些以执导这些剧集而闻名的导演，不仅仅是喜剧，它有戏剧性的元素，是关于真实的人。
And so by having some of these directors who are known for doing these dramas, these character-driven stories, I think that might've been why he was drawn to them. I'm speculating, but that feels right. I like your speculation. I like it. Thank you.
所以通过聘请一些以执导这些剧集而闻名的导演，这些以角色为驱动的故事，我想这可能就是他被他们吸引的原因。我是在推测，但这感觉是对的。我喜欢你的推测。我喜欢它。谢谢。
Okay, I am moving us to fast fact number three. In this episode, Michael circulates a photo of himself and Jan in Jamaica on their vacation. Yes. And then the guys in the warehouse blow it up into a poster and hang it on the wall. Mm-hmm. Right. All right. We got a lot of mail about this picture.
好的，我带大家进入第三个冷知识。在这一集中，迈克尔分发了一张他和简在牙买加度假的照片。是的。然后仓库里的伙计们把它放大成海报挂在墙上。嗯哼。对。好的。我们收到了很多关于这张照片的邮件。
Yeah. We have a fan question from Prisha Singhal, Amanda McKnight, Megan Kiel, Meredith Warlow, Stephanie Callahan, and many others they want to know. Was the Jan Michael photo made? Was it Photoshopped? Some people wanna know if Steve and Melora went to Jamaica to take this picture. Did they do a photo shoot there? How was this picture made?
是的。我们有一个来自普里莎·辛格尔、阿曼达·麦克奈特、梅根·基尔、梅雷迪思·沃洛、斯蒂芬妮·卡拉汉和其他许多人的粉丝提问，他们想知道。这张简和迈克尔的照片是怎么制作的？是PS的吗？有些人想知道史蒂夫和梅洛拉是否真的去了牙买加拍这张照片。他们在那里拍了写真吗？这张照片是怎么制作的？
A lot of curiosity about this picture. We never had the budget to all go to New York or Scranton. So I doubt they went to Jamaica. Just kidding, I know they didn't. They did not. Well, I reached out to Kent Zbornak, Kentopedia, and also to Phil Shea Props, and they explained how we made this photo and poster. Are you ready? Yes. Kent told me that they built a tiny beach down in the warehouse, a little like set that looked like a beach.
对这张照片有很多好奇。我们从来没有预算让所有人去纽约或斯克兰顿。所以我怀疑他们去了牙买加。开个玩笑，我知道他们没去。他们没去。嗯，我联系了肯特·兹博纳克，肯特百科，还有道具师菲尔·谢，他们解释了我们是如何制作这张照片和海报的。准备好了吗？是的。肯特告诉我，他们在仓库里建了一个小小的海滩，一个看起来像海滩的小布景。
It had sand and lounge chairs, and it was against a green screen. I remember that. I remember us all seeing it and being like walking over there. I have a total memory of going down into the warehouse and there was this tiny beach. And then he said that he and Phil Shea reached out to the people at Sandals Resort, who donated all kinds of products, which they featured, like the umbrellas and all of the stuff that said Sandals. They put it all in there.
它有沙子和躺椅，背景是绿幕。我记得那个。我记得我们都看到了它，就像走过去一样。我完全记得走进仓库，那里有一个小小的海滩。然后他说他和菲尔·谢联系了桑德尔斯度假村的人，他们捐赠了各种产品，比如雨伞和所有写着“桑德尔斯”的东西。他们把这些都放进去了。
So then Melora and Steve got on the little beach set and they took a bunch of pictures. And both Justin and Kent remember that, you know, Melora did not have to get nudie for this. They did that in Photoshop, you guys. And Phil told me that then he had the posters printed from a little graphics shop in Culver City. And that is how they made the picture.
所以梅洛拉和史蒂夫上了那个小海滩布景，拍了一堆照片。贾斯汀和肯特都记得，你知道，梅洛拉不需要为了这个裸露。他们是在Photoshop里做的，伙计们。菲尔告诉我，然后他让卡尔弗城的一家小图形店打印了海报。这就是他们制作照片的方式。
That was some good fast facts, lady. Hey, well, thanks. All right, why don't we take a break, Jenna, and when we come back, we'll be back from vacation. I like it. Why just survive back to school when you can thrive by creating a space that does it all for you, no matter the size?
那是一些很棒的冷知识，女士。嘿，谢谢。好了，我们休息一下，珍娜，回来后，我们将从假期归来。我喜欢。为什么在可以创造一个为你完成一切的空间时，还要仅仅在返校季中生存，无论空间大小？
Whether you're taking over your parents' basement or moving to campus, IKEA has hundreds of design ideas and affordable options to compliment any budget. After all, you're in your small space era. It's time to own it. Shop now at ikea.ca. All right, so we are back and let's get into this episode. There's a really fun cold open. It's Jim. He's got the sales team in the conference room because he's in charge while Michael's away and he's running this sort of sales meeting. Dwight, of course, I'm sure is bumping up
无论你是接管父母的地下室还是搬到校园，宜家都有数百种设计理念和经济实惠的选择，以满足任何预算。毕竟，你正处于你的小空间时代。是时候掌控它了。现在就在ikea.ca购物吧。好了，我们回来了，让我们进入这一集。有一个非常有趣的冷开场。是吉姆。他在会议室里召集了销售团队，因为迈克尔不在时他负责，他正在主持这个销售会议。德怀特，当然，我敢肯定正在
against Jim and his authority. So he sets a little recorder in the middle of the table to record the meeting. And then Jim, of course, has to mess with him. He has to mess with him. He starts being like, Dwight, why are your pants off? And he's like, my pants aren't off. And then everyone starts chiming in. And then of course, Andy takes it to an absurd place and is the fun stopper.
挑战吉姆和他的权威。所以他在桌子中间放了一个小录音机来记录会议。然后吉姆，当然，不得不捉弄他。他不得不捉弄他。他开始说，“德怀特，为什么你脱了裤子？”他说，“我没脱裤子。”然后每个人都开始附和。然后当然，安迪把它带到了一个荒谬的地方，成了扫兴的人。
Yeah. We had a fan question about this cold open from Sam Terizaz and Eva Mars, how much of the cold open was improvised? And, Ange, I went to the script and it's basically all scripted. Like, all of the stuff that Jim says that Dwight is doing and Karen's line and all of that, all scripted. I would have thought it was scripted.
是的。我们有一个关于这个冷开场的粉丝提问，来自萨姆·特里扎兹和伊娃·马斯，这个冷开场有多少是即兴创作的？而且，安吉，我看了剧本，它基本上全是写好的。就像，吉姆说的德怀特正在做的所有事情，凯伦的台词，所有这些，都是写好的。我本来以为是写好的。
I feel like this is our writers at their best. Like, they were so great at heightening a comedic moment. So that tracks for me. I did write down everything that Jim accused Dwight of doing. Do you want to hear? Of course. Okay, so first of all, he says, Dwight, you're not allowed to take off your pants
我觉得这是我们编剧的最佳状态。他们非常擅长提升喜剧时刻。所以这对我来说很合理。我确实写下了吉姆指控德怀特做的所有事情。你想听吗？当然。好的，首先，他说，“德怀特，你不允许在办公室中间脱掉裤子。”
in the middle of the office. And then he's like, oh God, he's got a knife. He's naked and he has the plastic knife to Stanley's neck. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. He's what? He's naked? Like his neck holding up his head? He's naked or he's naked? This is like a whole thing. My husband's always like say that again.
然后他说，“哦天哪，他有把刀。他赤身裸体，还把塑料刀架在斯坦利的脖子上。”抱歉。抱歉。他什么？他赤身裸体？就像他的脖子支撑着他的头？他是赤身裸体还是赤身裸体？这简直是一整件事。我丈夫总是说再说一遍。
Naked. Naked. Naked. How do you say it? Naked. It's an A. It's spelled N-A-K-E-D. Naked. Where I'm from is naked. To be fair, it is also naked where I'm from as well. Really? In St. Louis, it's naked? Well, in Missouri. It's interesting. St. Louis and Missouri have two different accents. If you're from St. Louis, you're from Missouri,
Naked（赤身裸体）。Naked。Naked。你怎么说？Naked。这是一个A。拼写是N-A-K-E-D。Naked。我来自的地方是Naked。公平地说，我来自的地方也是Naked。真的吗？在圣路易斯，是Naked？嗯，在密苏里州。很有趣。圣路易斯和密苏里州有两种不同的口音。如果你来自圣路易斯，你来自密苏里州，
but if you're from outside of St. Louis, you're from Missouri and you're naked. But if you're from St. Louis, you eat with a fork. Yes, that's what Phyllis would always say. She'd be like, oh, I can't find my fork. Right. So she would eat her dinner naked with a fork in Missouri, but someone else is going to eat it with a fork fork in Missouri. But someone else is gonna eat it with a fork naked in Missouri. Well, Jenna, if you're in North Texas, don't run around naked. And then he also says that Dwight has a baby's bonnet.
但如果你来自圣路易斯以外，你来自密苏里州，而且你是Naked。但如果你来自圣路易斯，你用叉子吃饭。是的，菲利斯总是这么说。她会说，“哦，我找不到我的叉子了。”对。所以她会在密苏里州赤身裸体地用叉子吃晚餐，但其他人会用叉子在密苏里州吃。但其他人会用叉子在密苏里州赤身裸体地吃。嗯，珍娜，如果你在北德克萨斯，不要赤身裸体地跑来跑去。然后他还说德怀特有一个婴儿帽。
And then Phyllis is so adorable. She's so adorable in this whole episode. She wants to desperately chime in and she's like, Jim Carrey's here. Get his autograph. You're like, what Carrey's here, get his autograph. You're like, what? And then Karen says, is that a Muppet Baby's tattoo on your belly?
然后菲利斯太可爱了。她在这一整集中都太可爱了。她非常渴望插话，她说，“金·凯瑞在这里。要他的签名。”你就像，什么凯瑞在这里，要他的签名。你就像，什么？然后凯伦说，“你肚子上那个是布偶宝贝的纹身吗？”
And then of course, Andy takes it to the place of, I'm chopping off Phyllis's head with a chainsaw. Ring, ring, ring, ring, ring, ring. My favorite part of all of that is that when Jim says, oh my God, Dwight is holding a plastic knife to Stanley's neck, the camera pans to Stanley and he does not even look up. He gives absolutely no reaction to everything that's happening in the room. It's awesome. It's amazing. It's amazing. I will point out that this conference room scene is a conference room table scene.
然后当然，安迪把它带到了“我正用电锯砍掉菲利斯的头”的地方。叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮。我最喜欢的部分是，当吉姆说，“哦天哪，德怀特正把一把塑料刀架在斯坦利的脖子上”时，摄像机转向斯坦利，他甚至没有抬头。他对房间里发生的一切完全没有反应。太棒了。太神奇了。太神奇了。我要指出，这个会议室场景是一个会议室桌子场景。
Noted, the table is in the room. Table is in the room. Let's move on. Sorry I took us on a detour with how I say Nicked. So now Michael has returned from Jamaica. He's super excited. He's desperate for Pam to ask him how his vacation was. But instead, Pam lets him know that Hannah quit while he was gone. And she's filed some complaints and he might have to be
注意到了，桌子在房间里。桌子在房间里。让我们继续。抱歉，我带我们绕道讨论了我怎么说Nicked。所以现在迈克尔从牙买加回来了。他超级兴奋。他非常渴望帕姆问他假期过得怎么样。但相反，帕姆告诉他汉娜在他离开时辞职了。她提出了一些投诉，他可能不得不被
deposed and Michael's like oh Pam it can wait and she's like it's kind of important. His exact response was blah blah blah relax. There's a really sweet deleted talking head that is a Pam talking head that I think would have come about right here and Jenna Jenna, guess what? She says that Michael sends her a postcard from every vacation he takes. I remember shooting this talking head. They gave me a bunch of postcards,
传唤，迈克尔说，“哦帕姆，这可以等。”她说，“这很重要。”他确切的回答是“blah blah blah，放松。”有一个非常可爱的删减采访镜头，是帕姆的采访镜头，我想应该就在这里，珍娜，珍娜，你猜怎么着？她说迈克尔从他去的每个假期都给她寄明信片。我记得拍摄这个采访镜头。他们给了我一堆明信片，
and I held them up one after the other, which I found sweet because that means Pam saves them. I know. And to me, it's like you just really see who Pam is to Michael. You see why ultimately she's the last person he speaks to before he leaves at the end of, you know, his time on the office. Like, he sees her as family. I really think he does. Well, we had a fan question for this opening scene. There's that moment where Michael shakes his hair at Pam because he's gotten some little beads in his hair on his vacation. I'm telling you, Sandals was like adult camp for Michael.
我把它们一张接一张地举起来，我觉得很甜，因为这意味着帕姆把它们保存了下来。我知道。对我来说，这就像你真的看到了帕姆对迈克尔来说是谁。你看到了为什么最终她是他在离开《办公室》时最后交谈的人。就像，他把她视为家人。我真的认为他是。嗯，我们对这个开场场景有一个粉丝提问。迈克尔对帕姆甩头发的那一刻，因为他在假期里在头发里弄了一些小珠子。我告诉你，桑德尔斯对迈克尔来说就像成人夏令营。
I mean, he says how you go, hey, mon, and then everyone yells, hey, mon. I can see him being so enthusiastic. He's going to do everything. Braid my hair, learn the dances, learn the chants. He's in it, Jenna. He's in it. You're right.
我的意思是，他说你怎么去，嘿，伙计，然后每个人都大喊，嘿，伙计。我能看出他有多热情。他什么都要做。编我的头发，学舞蹈，学口号。他沉浸其中，珍娜。他沉浸其中。你是对的。
Well, we had this question from Ashley Browning, Hope Cogville, Jess Graham, Rachel LaPointe, and Teresa Rambucuella. They want to know whose idea was it to put the beads in the hair. Were they sewn in? Were they glued in? Well, Jenna, you know, we wanted to get the behind in the hair? Were they sewn in? Were they glued in? Well, Jenna, you know, we wanted to get the behind the scenes story on this braid.
嗯，我们收到了阿什利·布朗宁、霍普·科格维尔、杰斯·格雷厄姆、雷切尔·拉波因特和特蕾莎·兰布奎拉的提问。他们想知道把珠子放在头发里的主意是谁出的。它们是缝进去的吗？是粘进去的吗？嗯，珍娜，你知道，我们想了解头发里的幕后故事。
So we reached out to Kim Ferry, who did our hair on the office for all the scoop. And this is what she had to say. Well, hello, lovely office ladies. Gosh darn it, I miss both of you so much. Thank you for asking me these questions. As usual, if there were any hair gags, Greg Daniels would either have me paged up or he would come find me and we would discuss
所以我们联系了金·费里，她在《办公室》里负责我们的发型，了解了所有内幕。这就是她要说的。嗯，你好，可爱的《办公室》女士们。天哪，我太想念你们俩了。谢谢你们问我这些问题。像往常一样，如果有任何发型噱头，格雷格·丹尼尔斯要么会传呼我，要么会来找我，我们会讨论
what the look would be for whatever the actors were doing in this episode. In this one, it was specifically Michael Scott. And I know on the makeup side, he was gonna be tan because they wanted him to kind of have that, you know, tan glow from Jamaica. But on my side, it was about having something in his hair. Could it be dreaded?
这一集中演员们要做的造型是什么。这一次，是迈克尔·斯科特。我知道在化妆方面，他会晒黑，因为他们想让他有一种来自牙买加的晒黑光泽。但在我这边，是要在头发里弄点东西。可以是脏辫吗？
Could it be beaded? You know, what could we do? And in the end, I kind of liked the idea of putting beads in, but I was a little nervous because his hair was only one inch on the sides and the back. He had a short haircut at that time. So I wasn't sure if something would stick in there,
可以是珠子吗？你知道，我们能做什么？最后，我有点喜欢放珠子的主意，但我有点紧张，因为他的头发两侧和后脑勺只有一英寸长。他当时留着短发。所以我不知道东西能不能粘在上面，
but I, you know, I rose to the challenge and told my team I was gonna be in the trailer for a little bit and I did a couple of variations of it. And I also had human hair. So you can have these actual real human hair clips and I would sew them into these little things called toupee clips. And I ended up braiding it down
但我，你知道，我迎接了挑战，告诉我的团队我会在拖车里待一会儿，我做了几个变体。而且我还有真人头发。所以你可以有这些真正的真人发夹，我会把它们缝进这些叫假发夹的小东西里。我最后把它编了下去，
probably about two inches long, two to three inches long. And at the very end, I had a little elastic on the bottom and that really held all the beads in place. and I know I had done a few options for Greg with different colors but in the end he liked the red and yellow and green so that's what we went with and the little clip it just kind of like hooks into the hair so it sticks really well and if I just back combed it a little bit and then a little bit of hairspray and then popped that clip in, it wasn't going anywhere.
大概两英寸长，两到三英寸长。最后，我在底部放了一根小橡皮筋，那真的把所有的珠子固定住了。我知道我为格雷格做了几个不同颜色的选择，但最后他喜欢红色、黄色和绿色，所以我们就用了那个。那个小夹子就像钩在头发里一样，所以它粘得很牢，如果我把它稍微倒梳一下，然后喷一点发胶，然后把那个夹子扣进去，它就不会动了。
And it didn't, it didn't move at all during that episode. So I was very happy. But that's just one of the things that I love doing. When I get challenges from Craig, it was always fun to not only make him happy after he saw it, but just to kind of really, he would just, he would enjoy it. It made me so happy after he saw it but just to kind of really he would just he would enjoy it it made me so happy when he would smile and he'd be like yeah yeah that's it so that is my story for this episode and I miss you both so much and
而且它确实没动，在那一集里一点都没动。所以我很高兴。但这只是我喜欢做的事情之一。当我从格雷格那里得到挑战时，不仅在他看到后让他高兴，而且真的，他会，他会享受它。这让我很高兴，在他看到后，他会微笑，他会说，“是的，是的，就是这样。”所以这就是我这一集的故事，我非常想念你们俩，
I'm sending you hugs and I'm so proud of you I love your podcast and I can't wait to hopefully join you guys there someday. All right, you guys take care. Love you both. Bye. Aw, that was so sweet. I love that. I love knowing that they didn't do anything to his actual hair. She would just clip that in and out every day. Yeah, I remember Kim always having these heads
我给你们拥抱，我为你们感到骄傲，我喜欢你们的播客，我迫不及待地希望有一天能加入你们。好了，你们保重。爱你们俩。再见。噢，那太甜了。我喜欢那个。我喜欢知道他们没有对他真正的头发做任何事。她每天只是把那个夹进去又取出来。是的，我记得金总是拿着这些头模，
with like different forms of hair and wigs and braids and like whatever she was tinkering on on she had like a row of like fake hair with like different versions of things especially for Meredith oh my gosh Meredith was always having something done to her hair so yeah thank you so much Kim for the behind the scenes on that one so listen and I know we're still talking about this opening scene, but I had to bring up something else. What?
上面有不同形式的头发、假发和辫子，无论她在捣鼓什么，她都有一排假发，有不同版本的，特别是为梅雷迪思准备的。哦，天哪，梅雷迪思总是要对她的头发做点什么。所以，是的，非常感谢金提供的幕后花絮。所以听着，我知道我们还在讨论这个开场场景，但我必须提出另一件事。什么？
So when Michael walks through the door, he's carrying like nine gazillion bags, right? And we're going to come to learn that one of them contains this steel drum that he is obsessed with playing. He's holding a box. He's holding bags and a box. And the steel drum, I think, is in the box, because it's a big box. He's holding bags and a box. And the steel drum, I think, is in the box
所以当迈克尔走进门时，他带着九万亿个包，对吧？我们要知道其中一个包里装着他沉迷于演奏的钢鼓。他拿着一个盒子。他拿着包和一个盒子。钢鼓，我想，在盒子里，因为它是一个大盒子。他拿着包和一个盒子，钢鼓，我想在盒子里，
because it's a big rectangle. Same. But it made me wonder what is in all the other bags. And that is an amazing deleted scene. Yes, Jenna. So those bags were gifts. They were like souvenirs that he bought everyone. They definitely look like the souvenirs
因为它是一个大长方形。我也是。但这让我好奇其他包里装的是什么。那是一个很棒的删减片段。是的，珍娜。那些包是礼物。它们就像他给每个人买的纪念品。它们看起来绝对像你在机场买的纪念品。
you bought at the airport. And it's all in the deleted scenes. He goes around the office handing them out. Well, I remember doing that scene because the thing he gives Pam is a coconut bra. And he's like, some coconuts for your coconuts. And I'm like, thanks. Then he says, do you wanna see if it fits?
而且全在删减片段里。他绕着办公室分发它们。嗯，我记得拍那场戏，因为他给帕姆的是一个椰子胸罩。他说，“给你的椰子一些椰子。”我说，“谢谢。”然后他说，“你想看看它合不合身吗？”
And you're like, no. I'm not gonna go try on this coconut bikini top right now. Thanks. Yes, exactly. But I remember shooting that with Steve because I couldn't get through it. Every time I opened it up, it was so ludicrous to me that that was the gift he gave Pam.
你说，“不。”我才不要现在去试穿这个椰子比基尼上衣。谢谢。是的，完全正确。但我记得和史蒂夫拍那场戏，因为我无法坚持下去。每次我打开它，对我来说，那是他给帕姆的礼物简直太荒谬了。
It would make me laugh. He gives Angela Martin a lei, and he puts it around her neck. And she's like, thank you. And he goes, you just got laid. And I'm like, no, I didn't. And you like rip it off, right? Yeah, I get really mad. Well, next we're gonna find out that Karen and Jim
这会让我笑。他给安吉拉·马丁一个花环，他把它戴在她的脖子上。她说，“谢谢。”他说，“你刚被‘戴’上了（laid，双关语）。”我说，“不，我没有。”然后你把它扯下来，对吧？是的，我真的很生气。嗯，接下来我们要发现凯伦和吉姆
are experiencing some tension. Oh yeah. And here is why. It is because Jim does not want Karen to move into an apartment that is two blocks away from his apartment, even though she's been having a really hard time finding an apartment and she is currently living in a motel.
正在经历一些紧张。哦，是的。原因如下。这是因为吉姆不想让凯伦搬进离他公寓两个街区远的公寓，尽管她一直很难找到公寓，而且她目前住在汽车旅馆里。
She said a day's in. That's what we learned that in the deleted scene. I mean, come on. Well, she says it down in the warehouse to Pam as well later. She needs to find a place to live. You know what I noticed? When Karen does her talking head, she's standing at the copier in the annex. Remember in the other episode we were like, is this copier always here? That's where she's standing. That's back by Kelly's desk and Toby's desk in the annex.
她说戴斯酒店。那是我们在删减片段里学到的。我的意思是，拜托。嗯，她后来在仓库里也对帕姆说了。她需要找个地方住。你知道我注意到了什么吗？当凯伦做采访镜头时，她站在附件的复印机旁。记得在另一集中我们说，“这个复印机一直在这里吗？”她就站在那里。那是在附件里凯利和托比的桌子后面。
Jenna, what does it mean if your talking head is in the annex? What does that mean? What does it mean? I think it means you're trying to avoid somebody and you're using the copier in the annex. Yeah. Jenna, speaking of deleted scenes,
珍娜，如果你的采访镜头在附件里意味着什么？那意味着什么？那意味着什么？我想这意味着你在试图避开某人，而你在使用附件里的复印机。是的。珍娜，说到删减片段，
there's another great runner between Phyllis and Stanley. Because Stanley says he doesn't get all of his bonus, and he's not going to work, not a lick, until he gets that bonus money. And it starts driving Phyllis crazy, because he won't answer his phone. She has a phenomenal talking head. So that's in the DVD Deleted Scenes.
菲利斯和斯坦利之间还有另一个很棒的跑动。因为斯坦利说他没有拿到他所有的奖金，在他拿到奖金之前，他不会工作，一点也不会。这让菲利斯快疯了，因为他不接电话。她有一个非凡的采访镜头。所以那在DVD删减片段里。
I remember shooting those, and they were very funny and I love any time there's a dynamic between Phyllis and Stanley. So now we're in Michael's office and he's playing the steel drum for Pam. He's telling her all about his trip to Jamaica. He's explaining that everyone in Jamaica just relaxes all day and they party all the time. They love it. Yeah. He's like, write this down, Pam. Pina colada is every day at 3 p.m.
我记得拍摄那些，它们非常有趣，我喜欢任何时候菲利斯和斯坦利之间有互动。所以现在我们在迈克尔的办公室，他正在为帕姆演奏钢鼓。他正在告诉她关于他牙买加旅行的一切。他解释说牙买加的每个人整天都在放松，他们一直在聚会。他们喜欢它。是的。他说，“写下来，帕姆。每天下午3点喝皮纳科拉达。”
Like he is just, he is definitely not ready to go back to work. And this is when Pam breaks the news to him that they have to do inventory, which is something that he was hoping to avoid by going on vacation. And she says, Michael, we can't do inventory without you. We had to wait. It has to be done today. He is so bummed out. He hates doing inventory. He says it's boring. So he decides to make it a party. And he tells Angela, get the party planning committee together, we're gonna have a luau this afternoon. And she is not having it.
就像他，他绝对没有准备好回去工作。这就是帕姆告诉他他们必须做库存的时候，这是他希望通过度假来避免的事情。她说，“迈克尔，没有你我们做不了库存。我们必须等。今天必须完成。”他非常沮丧。他讨厌做库存。他说这很无聊。所以他决定把它变成一个派对。他告诉安吉拉，召集派对策划委员会，我们今天下午要举办一个卢奥派对。而她根本不想参加。
She's like, what? At four minutes, you get a shot of a real snarky expression from Angela Martin about this luau that she now has to throw. But please look at the outfit. Crazy blouse with a high collar, froufy collar, Argyle sweater in shades of beige and brown,
她说，“什么？”在四分钟时，你看到了安吉拉·马丁对这个她现在必须举办的卢奥派对的一个非常刻薄的表情。但请看这套衣服。带有高领的疯狂衬衫，褶皱领，米色和棕色调的菱形毛衣，
brown skirt, ponytail with what Kim Ferry and I called the sloop. This is a classic Angela Martin outfit, if I have to say so myself. Well, lady, we had a fan question from Katie Wegman, who is asking, is the shirt that you're wearing the same one you were in Benny Hawn at Christmas because it looks almost identical? No, it is not.
棕色裙子，马尾辫，配上金·费里和我称之为“sloop”的东西。如果我不得不说的话，这是一套经典的安吉拉·马丁服装。嗯，女士，我们有一个来自凯蒂·韦格曼的粉丝提问，她问，你穿的那件衬衫和你圣诞节在贝尼·霍恩穿的是同一件吗，因为它看起来几乎一模一样？不，不是。
This season, the wardrobe department had bought me all of these high-collared, frouffy blouses, which only live this season and never come back. But that is not the same one. It's yet another frofy boss. Well now we go into the conference room Angela because Michael wants everyone to watch a video slideshow on island life and a big thing happens. Karen does not sit next to Jim. Yeah. It's serious. This fight is serious. And then while they're watching this slideshow, Pam spots Jan on the beach with Michael,
这一季，服装部门给我买了所有这些高领的、褶皱花边的衬衫，它们只在这一季出现，以后再也不会有了。但那件不是同一件。那是另一件褶皱花边衬衫。好了，现在我们要去会议室了，安吉拉，因为迈克尔想让大家看一段关于岛屿生活的视频幻灯片，然后发生了一件大事。凯伦没有坐在吉姆旁边。是的。这很严重。这场争吵很严重。然后当他们看幻灯片的时候，帕姆在海滩上发现了简和迈克尔在一起，
but he denies that it's her. Jenna, hold up. I have written down here, Pam pulls a Michael. Pam, why did you call it out? Why? I mean, that's something Michael would do. I feel like a normal move for Pam would be to notice Jan,
但他否认那是她。珍娜，等一下。我这里写着，帕姆学了迈克尔。帕姆，你为什么要把它指出来？为什么？我的意思是，那是迈克尔会做的事。我觉得帕姆正常的举动应该是注意到简，
totally know it was her, and not say anything. And instead, be like, oh, right? And then maybe go be chatty with Jim about it later. But instead, Pam points at the screen and goes, wait, is that Jan? That's Jan. And I feel like that's something Michael or Dwight would have done normally.
完全知道那是她，然后什么都不说。相反，她会说，哦，是吗？然后可能稍后再和吉姆聊这件事。但帕姆却指着屏幕说，等等，那是简吗？那是简。我觉得那是迈克尔或德怀特通常会做的事。
I totally hear that. I think that's a valid analysis. I will say I think it was probably so shocking to Pam that she just blurted it out. I mean, it's to see Jan in the picture. She just, I imagine she was just like, oh my gosh. Okay, okay, fair enough. Okay, I get it. Well, we had a fan question about this scene, Angela, from Marin Allen. She wrote in to say, my 13-year-old daughter, Dakota, pointed out that when Pam notices Jan
我完全同意。我认为这是一个合理的分析。我想说，我猜这对帕姆来说可能太震惊了，以至于她脱口而出。我的意思是，在照片里看到简。我想象她当时只是想，天哪。好吧，好吧，有道理。好吧，我明白了。嗯，我们有一个关于这个场景的粉丝提问，安吉拉，来自马林·艾伦。她写信说，我13岁的女儿达科塔指出，当帕姆注意到简
in Michael's vacation slideshow, Michael says that she's actually a German woman named Ergelgrue. And my daughter would like to know if this name was improvised and if it has anything to do with Steve's Despicable Me character Gru. I had the same question.
出现在迈克尔的度假幻灯片中时，迈克尔说她其实是一个叫厄格尔格鲁的德国女人。我女儿想知道这个名字是不是即兴创作的，它是否与史蒂夫在《神偷奶爸》中的角色格鲁有关。我也有同样的问题。
So I looked it up. This episode was filmed in 2007, back from vacation. Despicable Me came out in 2010. So then I researched animation production and how long it takes a movie like Despicable Me to be made, and they take three to five years. So it is possible that there was an overlap that Steve was doing voiceover
所以我查了一下。这一集是在2007年拍摄的，度假归来。《神偷奶爸》是在2010年上映的。所以我研究了动画制作，以及像《神偷奶爸》这样的电影制作需要多长时间，它们需要三到五年。所以有可能存在重叠，史蒂夫在做配音，
while we were filming on The Office. It's possible. Oh my gosh, and maybe that is why because in the script it says Earl-Grah but he says Urkel-Gruh maybe it was like on his mind and that's why he said Gru. Let's move it on Michael I mean he's got to tell someone right? He's so excited to tell Packer that Jan went with him to Jamaica and Packer doesn't believe him. He's like, no way. So Michael's like, you know what? I'll send you a picture. And Packer's email is Packer at
而我们当时正在拍摄《办公室》。这是有可能的。天哪，也许这就是原因，因为剧本里写的是厄尔-格拉，但他说是厄格尔-格鲁，也许这就在他的脑海里，所以他才说了格鲁。让我们继续，迈克尔，我的意思是，他得告诉某人，对吧？他太兴奋了，想告诉帕克简和他一起去了牙买加，而帕克不相信他。他说，不可能。所以迈克尔说，你知道吗？我会发一张照片给你。帕克的邮箱是帕克@
Dunder Mifflin, but he sends it to Packaging at Dunder Mifflin. And how this all goes down in the scene is so great because Michael is like, did you get it? Hit refresh. Hit refresh. And Packer is like, no, I didn't get it. And then all of a sudden he says, oh, I just got it from someone else.
邓德·米夫林，但他发给了邓德·米夫林的包装部。这个场景的进展非常棒，因为迈克尔说，你收到了吗？刷新一下。刷新一下。帕克说，不，我没收到。然后突然他说，哦，我刚从别人那里收到了。
And then Michael's like, wait, wait, what? Who else? What? And then Michael realizes he has sent it to the wrong place. He sent it to Daryl in the warehouse. Who has clearly forwarded it to Packer or someone else who forwarded it to Packer. But it is out, basically.
然后迈克尔说，等等，等等，什么？还有谁？什么？然后迈克尔意识到他发错地方了。他发给了仓库里的达里尔。达里尔显然把它转发给了帕克，或者其他人转发给了帕克。但基本上，它已经传出去了。
I want to point out that that line at the end, when Packer says, how do I get you out of this picture? That was an improv. That was a Dave Keckner ad. Yeah, that's Dave Keckner at his best. After Michael gets off the phone with Packer, he is freaked out. Oh, he's freaking the heck out.
我想指出最后那句台词，当帕克说，我怎么才能把你从这张照片里弄出去？那是即兴表演。那是戴夫·科克纳的加戏。是的，那是戴夫·科克纳的最佳表现。迈克尔挂断帕克的电话后，他吓坏了。哦，他吓得要死。
He needs to do damage control. So he runs, he sprints to the warehouse. We had a fan question from Anna Rhodes. She says, at seven minutes, 20 seconds, where is that hallway that Michael is running down to get to the warehouse? Anna, I had the same question. So I did some digging, but Jenna, I know you did too.
他需要进行危机公关。所以他跑，他冲向仓库。我们有一个来自安娜·罗兹的粉丝提问。她说，在7分20秒时，迈克尔跑向仓库的那条走廊在哪里？安娜，我也有同样的问题。所以我做了一些挖掘，但珍娜，我知道你也做了。
And you went to Kentopedia. So what do you got? All right, Kent told me that that is the hallway where our writers work. He is running down the writers' hallway. All those doors you see are writers' offices. And when he turns the corner and he runs through that doorway, he is running into Mindy Kaling's office. Is he really?
你去了肯托百科。你查到了什么？好吧，肯告诉我那是我们编剧工作的走廊。他正沿着编剧的走廊跑。你看到的所有那些门都是编剧的办公室。当他转过拐角跑过那个门口时，他跑进了敏迪·卡灵的办公室。真的是吗？
Yes. Oh my God. I thought that was Kent's office. Oh my gosh. Okay. I love that. Well, I have a little catch, Jenna. He runs past a woman sitting at a desk, right? Right at the very beginning of his sprint. Well, that is Mary Wall, and she was our executive producer assistant.
是的。天哪。我以为那是肯的办公室。天哪。好吧。我喜欢这个。嗯，我有一个小发现，珍娜。他跑过一个坐在桌子旁的女人，对吧？就在他冲刺的最开始。嗯，那是玛丽·沃尔，她是我们的执行制片人助理。
She's in an orange hoodie. She was the best. She did everything for us. I love that we put Mary in that scene. So I guess they just made all the writers close their doors, She was the best. She did everything for us. I love that we put Mary in that scene. So I guess they just made all the writers close their doors, but they let Mary keep working and they just shot that scene. Steve ran right past her.
她穿着一件橙色的连帽衫。她是最好的。她为我们做了所有事。我很高兴我们把玛丽放进了那个场景。所以我猜他们只是让所有编剧关上门，但他们让玛丽继续工作，然后他们就拍了那个场景。史蒂夫直接从她身边跑过。
Yeah. And the desk that Mary is sitting at is directly outside of the writer's room conference room. They had their own conference room and Steve starts his sprint right in the doorway of that writer's room conference room, and he runs right past Mary at the desk outside of it. Well, after he runs into Mindy's office, obviously it's a dead end, so they had to cut there. Then Steve had to go down into the warehouse,
是的。玛丽坐的桌子就在编剧室会议室的外面。他们有自己的会议室，史蒂夫就在那个编剧室会议室的门口开始冲刺，他直接跑过了坐在外面的玛丽的桌子。嗯，在他跑进敏迪的办公室后，显然那是死胡同，所以他们不得不剪辑到那里。然后史蒂夫不得不下到仓库，
walk up the steps, and get into that little fake box at the top of the stairs that actually leads nowhere. And then come back down. Yes. And then they would yell, action, and he would come running back down the stairs as if he had actually come from somewhere. Right. So then he runs into Daryl's office.
走上台阶，进入楼梯顶端那个实际上哪儿也不通的小假盒子里。然后又走下来。是的。然后他们会喊，开始，他就会跑下楼梯，好像他真的从什么地方过来一样。对。然后他跑进了达里尔的办公室。
And I believe, Angela, this is the first time we've seen Daryl's office in the warehouse where we've actually gone inside of it. In this scene at seven minutes 38 seconds, Daryl is eating a giant plate of food. We had a fan question from Dave H and Andrea Poteet Bell. What is up with Daryl's massive plate of food when Michael goes in to ask him about the picture? Well, Angela, it is not in the script that Darryl is eating. And usually it is. Usually it is scripted that we're eating food. Here's why I went to look.
而且我相信，安吉拉，这是我们第一次在仓库里看到达里尔的办公室，我们真的进去了。在这个7分38秒的场景中，达里尔正在吃一大盘食物。我们有一个来自戴夫·H和安德里亚·波蒂特·贝尔的粉丝提问。当迈克尔进去问他关于照片的事时，达里尔那盘巨大的食物是怎么回事？嗯，安吉拉，剧本里没有写达里尔在吃东西。通常是有的。通常剧本里会写我们在吃东西。这就是为什么我去查了一下。
When I looked at that plate of food, it 100% looked like the stuff they would serve us at craft services. I thought the same thing. Jenna, oh my god. When I looked at it, I was like, is Craig, as Daryl, just holding his lunch? Or like a snack he made?
当我看到那盘食物时，它100%看起来像是他们在后勤服务处提供给我们的东西。我也这么想。珍娜，天哪。当我看到它时，我想，克雷格作为达里尔，是在拿着他的午餐吗？还是他做的零食？
Yeah. I think he was hungry, and he was having a plate of food. And they were like, oh, you should just eat that in the scene. That food brought me back. I had a sense memory when I saw the plate. I was like, that's our food. That's what we used to eat all the scene. That food brought me back. I had a sense memory when I saw the plate. I was like, that's our food. That's what we used to eat all the time. Yeah, especially like they would bring in those big trays of chicken wings. Remember?
是的。我想他饿了，他有一盘食物。他们就说，哦，你应该在场景里吃那个。那食物让我想起了过去。当我看到那盘子时，我有一种感官记忆。我想，那是我们的食物。那是我们过去常吃的东西。是的，特别是他们会带进那些大盘的鸡翅。记得吗？
Yes. Like drumsticks and wings. Yes. Well, so when Michael is there, he's asking Darryl, did you get my email? Did you? And Darryl's like, yeah. And he's like, well, did you get my email about deleting that email? And Darrell's like, You know what, Mike, I'm very busy down here. So clearly Darrell is going to be no help in getting Michael's picture deleted. Oh, no. Well, I want to take us back to accounting for a second, Jenna humor me for some background catches at eight minutes, 12 seconds, Andy, Meredith, and Jim are gathered around Kevin's computer looking at the photo.
是的。像鸡腿和鸡翅。是的。嗯，所以当迈克尔在那里时，他问达里尔，你收到我的邮件了吗？收到了吗？达里尔说，收到了。他说，嗯，你收到我关于删除那封邮件的邮件了吗？达里尔说，你知道吗，迈克，我在这儿很忙。所以显然达里尔在帮迈克尔删除照片方面帮不上忙。哦，不。嗯，我想带大家回到会计部一会儿，珍娜，满足我一下，看看8分12秒的一些背景细节，安迪、梅雷迪思和吉姆围在凯文的电脑前看那张照片。
Now, over Kevin's shoulder, you can see a message on his bulletin board that says, don't eat the yellow snow. Maybe Kevin needed a reminder, but at eight minutes, 18 seconds, there is a post-it note on Angela Martin's side of the partition. And Jenna, I zoomed in on that sucker. I zoomed on it so hard. And do you know what it says? We got so much mail about this post-it note. Angela, you're going to make so many
现在，在凯文的肩膀上方，你可以看到他公告栏上的一条信息，写着，不要吃黄雪。也许凯文需要提醒，但在8分18秒，安吉拉·马丁那边的隔板上有一张便利贴。珍娜，我放大了那个小东西。我放大了好久。你知道上面写什么吗？我们收到了很多关于这张便利贴的邮件。安吉拉，你现在会让很多人
people very happy right now. What does it say? Well, I have to thank my husband Josh because this was half an hour of our lives that I made him do with me. He has editing software. I made him screen grab, blow it up. We put different filters on it that would highlight different letters. You guys, it was a huge task, but we did it.
非常高兴。上面写什么？嗯，我得感谢我的丈夫乔希，因为这是我让他和我一起做的半小时生活。他有编辑软件。我让他截屏，放大。我们给它加了不同的滤镜来突出不同的字母。伙计们，这是一个巨大的任务，但我们做到了。
This is what we 99.9% believe that it says after our half an hour research, Angela, comma, can I have $8 petty cash to buy some more jelly beans? I'll get you licorice and cherry. Thanks, Pam. Oh my gosh. I'll get you licorice and cherry.
这就是我们99.9%确信它写的内容，在我们半小时的研究之后，安吉拉，逗号，我可以要8美元的零用现金去买更多的软糖吗？我会给你买甘草糖和樱桃味的。谢谢，帕姆。天哪。我会给你买甘草糖和樱桃味的。
Well, you know that Dwight likes licorice. Wow. I guess you're the one who likes cherry. I guess so. But we literally, it was like, it was like we had found the Rosetta Stone. We're like, that's an R. I'm positive. Okay, that's a C. That's a Y. Like, literally, like we were like, figuring out hieroglyphics. And we became obsessed. And that's what we're pretty sure it says. Well, what I love about that is that it reveals that Pam doesn't pay for her own candy. She gets petty cash from Angela, and that it is something that Pam is doing for the office,
嗯，你知道德怀特喜欢甘草糖。哇。我猜你才是那个喜欢樱桃味的人。我想是吧。但我们真的，就像我们发现了罗塞塔石碑一样。我们说，那是个R。我肯定。好吧，那是C。那是Y。就像，我们真的像是在破译象形文字。我们变得着迷了。这就是我们确信它写的内容。嗯，我喜欢的是它揭示了帕姆不为自己的糖果买单。她从安吉拉那里得到零用现金，而且这是帕姆为办公室做的事情，
almost like maybe the person before her did it too. I could imagine Pam starting work and Angela going up to her and saying, you will put out candy on your desk. I will give you petty cash. You need to bring me a receipt. But like this is part of Pam's like work list. Yeah, it made me rethink front reception too, especially during the holidays because I thought all those little decorations, I always sort of
几乎就像她之前的人也这样做一样。我可以想象帕姆开始工作，安吉拉走到她面前说，你得在桌子上放糖果。我会给你零用现金。你需要给我收据。但这就像是帕姆工作清单的一部分。是的，这让我重新思考前台，特别是在假期期间，因为我以为所有那些小装饰，我总是觉得
thought that was Pam's effort to spruce up her desk area. But now I think maybe Angela Martin is like, remember, you have a budget for decorating the front reception. It's the first thing people see when they walk through the door. Yeah, like this candy and the decorations are mandated. Can we though believe that Pam buys the plants herself? If you want to. Thanks. She can't keep any of them alive. Okay.
那是帕姆为了美化她的办公桌区域所做的努力。但现在我想也许安吉拉·马丁会说，记住，你有装饰前台的预算。这是人们走进门时看到的第一件事。是的，就像这些糖果和装饰品是强制性的。不过我们能相信帕姆自己买植物吗？如果你想的话。谢谢。她养不活任何一盆。好吧。
Okay. All right. So now we have two things happening. We have Michael who tells Dwight about the photo. He says he needs Dwight's help in retrieving it. My favorite part of this scene is when we learn that Michael has named the photo Jamaican Jan Sun Princess. Amazing. And then the other thing that happens is that Jim,
好吧。好的。所以现在有两件事在发生。迈克尔告诉德怀特关于照片的事。他说他需要德怀特的帮助来找回它。这个场景我最喜欢的部分是当我们得知迈克尔给这张照片命名为“牙买加简太阳公主”。太棒了。然后发生的另一件事是吉姆，
sad, sad Jim is in the break room. Pam walks in and she gets Jim to confide in her. And he says that he is in kind of a stupid fight with Karen. And Pam says, do you want to talk about it? I have a question for you. What? Do you really think that Pam wants to talk about it? Or do you think somewhere deep in her subconscious,
悲伤的、悲伤的吉姆在休息室。帕姆走进来，她让吉姆向她倾诉。他说他和凯伦吵了一架，很蠢。帕姆说，你想谈谈吗？我有一个问题要问你。什么？你真的认为帕姆想谈谈吗？还是你认为在她的潜意识深处，
I don't think she's a mean spirited person, but maybe she has found a way just to spend time with him again? Of course. Of course. She has ulterior motives here. Well, I think it's also though, you know what, I actually don't think she has those ulterior motives.
我不认为她是一个心胸狭窄的人，但也许她只是找到了一种能再次和他共度时光的方法？当然。当然。她在这里有不可告人的动机。嗯，但我认为这也是，你知道吗，我其实不认为她有那些不可告人的动机。
I think she is really trying to believe and convince herself that she can have a friendship with Jim and that this is what friends do. So yes, I think part of her is craving that connection. But I think the real thing and why she's going to break down later is that she thinks she's ready to be this kind of friend to him. And she's going to find out that she's not.
我认为她真的在努力相信并说服自己，她可以和吉姆建立友谊，这就是朋友所做的事。所以是的，我想她的一部分渴望那种联系。但我认为真正的原因，以及为什么她后来会崩溃，是因为她认为她已经准备好成为他这样的朋友了。而她会发现她并没有。
Right. But she thinks that she is. And this is her attempt. Well, I'll tell you, there's a deleted scene between Jim and Pam. I'm actually, for their storyline, I think it was the right thing to delete it, because it takes Pam's
对。但她认为她是。这是她的尝试。嗯，我告诉你，吉姆和帕姆之间有一个被删减的场景。其实，对于他们的故事情节，我认为删除它是正确的，因为它带走了帕姆
sort of earnestness to want to help him and try to really be a good friend to him. And it makes it seem like maybe she just wanted to hang out with him. And it's the two of you at front reception at Pam's computer, kind of in that canoodling form, the way you guys used to play and pranks on Dwight and he'd be leaning in, you'd be laughing and looking at each other. You're doing all of that, but you're looking for apartments together for Karen. Oh.
那种想要帮助他并努力成为他好朋友的真诚。这让它看起来好像她只是想和他在一起。那是你们两个在前台，在帕姆的电脑前，那种亲昵的样子，就像你们过去捉弄德怀特时那样，他会凑过来，你们会笑，看着对方。你们在做所有这些，但你们是在一起为凯伦找公寓。哦。
And it felt, it felt off. And so I think it was the right move to delete it. I'm glad they deleted that because my takeaway from this episode was that Pam was being really earnest. Yeah. And then just realized she can't. She can't be that yet. Well, we also get a big piece of information
这感觉，感觉不对劲。所以我认为删除它是正确的举动。我很高兴他们删除了那个，因为我对这一集的理解是帕姆表现得非常真诚。是的。然后只是意识到她不能。她还不能那样。嗯，我们还在这个场景中得到了关于吉姆和凯伦关系的一大块信息。
about Jim and Karen's relationship in the scene. We find out that they've been dating a month. Jim says, we've only been dating a month. That is not very long. No. So definitely the whole dating thing started after she moved to Scranton. Because we are about four weeks into her move. That kind of makes Jim's argument make sense. I mean, if you've just started dating someone, you're only dating them a month,
我们发现他们已经约会一个月了。吉姆说，我们才约会一个月。那时间不长。不。所以绝对是约会这件事是在她搬到斯克兰顿之后开始的。因为她搬来已经大约四周了。这让吉姆的论点变得合理了。我的意思是，如果你刚开始和某人约会，你们才约会一个月，
you might not want them living right down the street because you're like, what if it doesn't work out? Yeah, but are you really going to see them that much unless you want to? I mean, it's not like they're direct neighbors or living in the same building. I don't know. Two blocks away is far if you want it to be. I don't know. I might be on gym site on this one. I might be like, hey, I want to be able to go for a walk or jog. I mean, who are we kidding? I'm not jogging anywhere. But my point is, I don't know. That might be too close.
你可能不想让他们住在街对面，因为你会想，如果没成怎么办？是的，但除非你想，否则你真的会经常见到他们吗？我的意思是，他们又不是直接的邻居或住在同一栋楼里。我不知道。如果你想的话，两个街区远也是很远的。我不知道。在这个问题上我可能站在吉姆这边。我可能会说，嘿，我想去散步或慢跑。我的意思是，我们在骗谁呢？我哪儿也不会去慢跑。但我的意思是，我不知道。那可能太近了。
So in the end, Pam tells Jim that she thinks maybe he's being unreasonable. Maybe he should reconsider. She very gently suggests this. And then they start giggling about the fact that Michael went to Jamaica with Jan. Yes. And that must feel like a little bit like,
所以最后，帕姆告诉吉姆，她认为也许他有点不讲理。也许他应该重新考虑。她非常温和地建议了这一点。然后他们开始因为迈克尔和简去了牙买加这件事而咯咯笑。是的。那一定感觉有点像，
like they're back, and that must make Pam happy. You know? That's like that moment. I want to give a little shout-out to a Toby line, because Toby confronts Michael in the next scene, saying that he has to report it if he's having a relationship, you know, with a coworker. And Michael's denying everything, but Toby says nine different people emailed me that photo,
就像他们回到了过去，那一定让帕姆很高兴。你知道吗？那就像那一刻。我想给托比的一句台词点个赞，因为托比在下一个场景中质问迈克尔，说如果他和同事有关系，他必须报告，你知道的。迈克尔否认了一切，但托比说有九个不同的人给我发了那张照片，
including my ex-wife and we don't even really talk. I love that. And then that made me laugh out loud. And then Michael's response is, well, maybe this will be the icebreaker. That's how Mike responds to that. But if it just shows you how far and wide this photo is going now. So now here's what's happening in the rest of the office.
包括我的前妻，我们甚至都不怎么说话。我喜欢那个。那让我大声笑了出来。然后迈克尔的回应是，嗯，也许这会成为破冰船。迈克尔就是这样回应的。但这只是向你展示了这张照片现在传播得有多广。所以现在这是办公室里正在发生的事情。
Angela's in the conference room. She has called together an emergency meeting of the party planning committee. How are they going to throw this luau? She's very stressed. Oh, she's not happy about it. So then the very next scene, we're all out in the bullpen again. We're done with our meeting, apparently. Pam is back at reception. She's fielding a phone call from Jan.
安吉拉在会议室。她召集了派对策划委员会的紧急会议。他们要怎么举办这个卢奥派对？她压力很大。哦，她对此很不高兴。所以紧接着下一个场景，我们又回到了办公区。显然我们开完会了。帕姆回到前台。她正在接简的电话。
This must be a time jump. Maybe it was a continuity error. I don't know. There's a little, there are a couple times when Pam is both in the break room talking to Jim and at the reception desk. Pam has superpowers. She's like all over the place. Pam is in a lot of places at once in this episode. But in this moment, Jan has called the office and Michael will not take the call. He is freaking out. He says he will call Jan back. And I want to note, Angela, not only are you not in the conference room at 12 minutes, 4 seconds, you are standing at the mail cart with Andy.
这一定是一个时间跳跃。也许这是一个连续性错误。我不知道。有几次帕姆既在休息室和吉姆说话，又在前台。帕姆有超能力。她就像无处不在。帕姆在这一集中同时出现在很多地方。但在这一刻，简给办公室打了电话，而迈克尔不接电话。他吓坏了。他说他会给简回电话。我想指出，安吉拉，在12分4秒你不仅不在会议室，你还和安迪站在邮件车旁。
Hold up, lady. Three seconds ago, you were shredding green construction paper to make decorations for the luau. Now you're at the mail cart. What's happening? Using the mail cart, apparently. Very important. Mail cart tracking. What? With Andy? Well, I have a question for you, Jenna. At 12 minutes, 14 seconds, Dwight opens Michael's office window, not the window that faces the bullpen,
等一下，女士。三秒钟前，你还在碎绿色建筑纸来做卢奥派对的装饰。现在你在邮件车旁。发生了什么？显然是在用邮件车。非常重要。邮件车追踪。什么？和安迪一起？嗯，我有一个问题要问你，珍娜。在12分14秒，德怀特打开了迈克尔办公室的窗户，不是面对办公区的窗户，
the window that faces like front reception in the couch, you know, the hallway as you come in. He slides the window open and tries to poke his head through the blinds to tell Michael he needs to come down to the warehouse ASAP. Yeah. Jenna, is that the first and only time that windows open? I'm not sure.
是面对前台和沙发的那扇窗户，你知道，你进来时的走廊。他把窗户滑开，试图把头从百叶窗里探出来，告诉迈克尔他需要尽快下到仓库。是的。珍娜，那是那扇窗户第一次也是唯一一次打开吗？我不确定。
I feel like we've opened that window before and there were other people who wrote in and pointed that out that why did Dwight do that? How did he do that? But yeah, he slid the window open and spoke through the blinds, I guess because he's been in the warehouse, he's run upstairs, and he needs to tell Michael immediately. And for some reason, I guess he thinks this is more secretive or something,
我觉得我们以前打开过那扇窗户，还有其他人写信指出过这一点，为什么德怀特要那样做？他是怎么做到的？但是的，他滑开了窗户，透过百叶窗说话，我猜是因为他一直在仓库里，他跑上楼，他需要立即告诉迈克尔。而且出于某种原因，我猜他认为这更隐秘或者什么的，
a way to get Michael's attention. I mean, it was so jarring to me. I'm like, Oh, God, Dwight, where are you coming from? What's happening? Well, then Michael and Dwight, they do that run down the hallway again. They go into the warehouse to discover that they have turned his picture with Jan into a giant poster and hung it on the wall. And all the guys start applauding for Michael. Michael is so conflicted in this moment. He doesn't know if he wants to be popular or if he wants to do the right thing. Yeah. And you know, Jan is legendary within this office. She is the corporate boss.
一种引起迈克尔注意的方法。我的意思是，这对我来说太刺耳了。我想，哦，天哪，德怀特，你从哪儿来的？发生了什么？嗯，然后迈克尔和德怀特，他们又跑下走廊。他们走进仓库，发现他们已经把他和简的照片做成了一张巨大的海报，挂在墙上。所有人都开始为迈克尔鼓掌。迈克尔在这一刻非常矛盾。他不知道他是想受欢迎还是想做正确的事。是的。而且你知道，简在办公室里是传奇人物。她是公司老板。
So this is a big story. And Michael is very conflicted. All right. Well, I think maybe we should take a break. And when we come back, we'll figure out how Michael is going to solve this problem and see if this luau party actually happens. Yes. ["The New York Times"] All right, we are back. Michael makes an announcement in the office and tells everyone that they have to delete this photo.
所以这是一个大新闻。迈克尔非常矛盾。好吧。嗯，我想也许我们应该休息一下。当我们回来时，我们会弄清楚迈克尔将如何解决这个问题，看看这个卢奥派对是否真的会发生。是的。["纽约时报"] 好吧，我们回来了。迈克尔在办公室宣布，告诉大家他们必须删除这张照片。
That is not Jan. It could be Jan, but it's not Jan. But whatever the case, just delete the photo. Then he goes down into the parking lot and he starts playing his steel drum again. It's a very wintery parking lot, too. Like the trees are covered in snow, but he's determined to play the only thing he knows, which is feeling hot, hot, hot. Yes, and only one note from that song can he play on the steel drum. But I'm really glad that you mentioned the weather, Angela, because we had to set all of that up.
那不是简。可能是简，但不是简。但无论如何，只要删除照片就行了。然后他下到停车场，又开始敲他的钢鼓。停车场也很冷。树上覆盖着雪，但他决心演奏他唯一会的东西，那就是“感觉热，热，热”。是的，而且他只能在钢鼓上敲出那首歌的一个音符。但我真的很高兴你提到了天气，安吉拉，因为我们必须安排好这一切。
We shot this in October, but of course this aired in the middle of winter. So we wanted to make sure that our seasons on the show coordinated with what would actually be happening in Scranton, Pennsylvania at the time. And it was my idea to not come all the way out the door. I said, Pam doesn't have her coat on. I think if this were really me, I would just sort of hover inside and kind of talk through a crack in the door when it's really cold. And I just love that that made that in. They liked that idea. And so that's why Pam doesn't come all the way outside to talk to Michael. Oh, I loved that. I didn't know
我们在十月拍摄，但当然这在冬天播出。所以我们想确保我们在剧中的季节与当时斯克兰顿实际发生的事情相协调。而且我提议不要一直走到门外。我说，帕姆没穿外套。我想如果这真的是我，我会在很冷的时候缩在里面，透过门缝说话。我真的很喜欢这个想法被采纳了。所以这就是为什么帕姆没有完全走到外面去和迈克尔说话。哦，我喜欢那个。我不知道
that. But it felt very real to me that you'd be like, Hey, idiot, come inside. Can I confess something? I really love when I get to pretend to be cold. Really? Yeah, because I'm cold all the time. I feel like I have such a full suitcase of material to pull from when I need to be cold. I'm cold constantly. And so that's why I was like, oh, you need me to pretend to be cold. Well, I'll tell you what I would do. I wouldn't walk all the way outside without a coat on. Let me throw that at you. And there was like, there was an episode, a few episodes ago where we were all in the parking lot
那个。但对我来说，你表现得像“嘿，白痴，进来”感觉非常真实。我可以坦白一件事吗？我真的很喜欢假装很冷的时候。真的吗？是的，因为我一直都很冷。我觉得当我需要假装冷的时候，我有一个装满素材的行李箱可以利用。我一直很冷。所以这就是为什么我说，哦，你需要我假装很冷。嗯，我告诉你我会怎么做。我不会在没穿外套的情况下一直走到外面。让我把这个抛给你。而且有，有几集之前我们在停车场
and we were pretending to be cold. And I saw myself, I kept putting my mouth down into the front of my coat and breathing into it because that's something I do when I'm cold. I'm noticing all of my cold detail acting and I'm really proud of it so I'm giving a little flex to it right now. All your cold schtick. You've got your cold schtick down.
我们假装很冷。我看到我自己，我一直把嘴缩进外套的前面，对着它呼吸，因为那是我冷的时候会做的事。我注意到了我所有的冷细节表演，我真的很自豪，所以我现在稍微炫耀一下。你所有的冷戏。你已经掌握了你的冷戏。
I own a sweatshirt that says always cold that my family gave to me as a gift because I drive everyone crazy. I sneak up behind and turn the thermostat off like I'm that person. So Jenna, I don't know if I'm great at pretending to be cold, but I'm with you. I mean you and I froze our butts off on that set. So now we're at the luau. Angela Martin is cutting up spam because... I guess that's all you could get. You couldn't get a full pig from the petting zoo, as you had told Phyllis. Oh, Lord.
我有一件写着“总是很冷”的运动衫，是我家人送给我的礼物，因为我让每个人都抓狂。我偷偷走到后面把恒温器关掉，就像我是那种人。所以珍娜，我不知道我是否擅长假装很冷，但我站在你这边。我的意思是，你和我在那片场冻得屁股都僵了。所以现在我们在卢奥派对。安吉拉·马丁正在切午餐肉，因为……我猜那是你能买到的全部。你不能像你告诉菲利斯的那样从宠物动物园弄到一整头猪。哦，天哪。
Well, my dad loves spam. So when I saw that, I just got tickled because it made me think of my dad. My dad, whenever he... My mom was really in charge of all the cooking and meal prep when I was growing up, unless it was barbecuing. Like, they were so traditional. My dad, like, manned the barbecue. But if my mom...
嗯，我爸爸喜欢午餐肉。所以当我看到那个时，我只是觉得很有趣，因为它让我想起了我爸爸。我爸爸，每当他……我成长过程中，我妈妈真的负责所有的烹饪和备餐，除非是烧烤。就像，他们太传统了。我爸爸，就像，负责烧烤。但如果我妈妈……
And it was very rare, but let's say my mom woke up and she's like, oh gosh, I have a cold, I have a fever, you know, whatever. One of those mornings where my dad had to take over, my dad would fry spam and we'd all be like, ah, and you'd be like, you're gonna have spam. And then he would fry it up for breakfast. And then if he had to make our lunch, you'd be like, well, we got leftover spam. It was like, dad, so much spam. What is spam? I think spam's a lot of parts. Does it have flavors in it? Is it a specific flavor?
而且这非常罕见，但假设我妈妈醒来说，哦天哪，我感冒了，我发烧了，你知道，什么的。那些我爸爸不得不接手的早晨之一，我爸爸会炸午餐肉，我们都会说，啊，你会说，你要吃午餐肉。然后他会把它炸了当早餐。然后如果他不得不做我们的午餐，你会说，嗯，我们有剩下的午餐肉。就像，爸爸，太多的午餐肉了。什么是午餐肉？我想午餐肉有很多部分。它有味道吗？它是一种特定的味道吗？
It's very salty. OK, wait. We're getting a message from Cody. This is the benefit of zooming our podcast. Our producer can pop on. She is telling us that spam's basic ingredients are, quote, pork with ham added, salt water, modified potato starch as a binder, sugar and sodium nitrate as a preservative.
它非常咸。好的，等等。我们收到了科迪的消息。这就是我们播客放大的好处。我们的制片人可以跳出来。她告诉我们，午餐肉的基本成分是，引用，猪肉加火腿，盐水，改性马铃薯淀粉作为粘合剂，糖和亚硝酸钠作为防腐剂。
There is also a natural gelatin that is formed during cooking in its tins on the production line. Cody's clarifying, ham is from the pig's hind leg while pork is any meat from pigs. Wait guys the spam conversation is not over. I know you were worried that we were stopping the spam conversation but Sam just threw down that there are 15 different flavors of spam. Okay well that seems crazy. It's what you're here for guys. It's what you're here for, guys. It's what you're here for. It's what you're here for. All right.
在生产线的罐头烹饪过程中还会形成一种天然明胶。科迪澄清说，火腿来自猪的后腿，而猪肉是猪身上的任何肉。等等伙计们，午餐肉的对话还没结束。我知道你们担心我们会停止午餐肉的对话，但萨姆刚刚抛出有15种不同口味的午餐肉。好吧，这看起来很疯狂。这就是你们来这里的原因，伙计们。这就是你们来这里的原因，伙计们。这就是你们来这里的原因。这就是你们来这里的原因。好吧。
Well, so yes, we're back to the luau in the warehouse. Jim gives Karen some papers. What are they, Jenna? Yes. He hands her a rental agreement for the apartment that is two blocks away from him. And they're so happy and they make up. You know, Angela, we got a lot of questions about why are they having this luau down in the warehouse.
嗯，所以是的，我们回到了仓库里的卢奥派对。吉姆给了凯伦一些文件。它们是什么，珍娜？是的。他递给她一份公寓的租赁协议，离他两个街区远。他们非常高兴，他们和好了。你知道，安吉拉，我们收到了很多关于为什么他们在仓库里举办这个卢奥派对的问题。
People were kind of confused. And I think that's because there were a bunch of scenes that got deleted from this section of the show that remind you that we're supposed to be doing inventory down there. There are so many deleted scenes from the warehouse. So there were all of these little vignettes. One of the ones I loved was that Ryan is staring at a bunch of boxes and he has like a clicker in his hand like you know
人们有点困惑。我认为这是因为这一节节目中删减了很多场景，提醒你我们应该在那里做库存。仓库里有太多被删减的场景。所以有所有这些小片段。我最喜欢的一个是瑞安盯着一堆盒子，他手里拿着一个点击器，就像你知道的那样
that you would check off like a barcode like beep beep and Roy walks up and goes what's the problem and Ryan's like well we're seven boxes short of whatever yellow paper whatever it was. And Roy just takes the clicker from Ryan and then just scans into the air like seven, and he goes fixed. So there's like, and Ryan's like, oh, so we're not doing we're just fudging it. But like, there's all these different moments within the warehouse that are happening that remind you that we're actually there to do inventory. Then another deleted scene that happens is Meredith is doing inventory and she's trying to get to one of the boxes on top of the shelf and she does that thing you guys I have done so many times especially in a grocery store when I can't reach something on the
你会像条形码一样勾选，哔哔，然后罗伊走过来问有什么问题，瑞安说，嗯，我们少了七盒黄色纸什么的。然后罗伊只是从瑞安手里拿过点击器，然后对着空气扫描，七，他说修好了。所以有，瑞安说，哦，所以我们不是在做，我们只是在敷衍。但就像，仓库里发生了所有这些不同的时刻，提醒你我们实际上是在那里做库存。然后另一个发生的被删减场景是梅雷迪思在做库存，她试图够到架子顶上的一个盒子，她做了那个你们伙计们我做过很多次的动作，特别是在杂货店里，当我够不到
top. I climb up the bottom of the shelf, and she does this, and the whole entire shelf comes crashing down on her head with all the boxes. She's completely buried. If you watch the deleted scenes, you can't even see Kate anymore. She's buried, no one notices, people just keep on business as usual, and then you hear this muffled voice say,
顶上的东西时。我爬上架子的底部，她做了这个，整个架子连同所有的盒子一起砸在她的头上。她完全被埋了。如果你看被删减的场景，你甚至看不到凯特了。她被埋了，没人注意到，人们只是继续照常工作，然后你听到这个闷闷的声音说，
hello, I'm stuck. Hello? We got a fan question about this moment. Jess Moore wrote in and said, did Kate Flannery do her own stunt in that deleted scene in the warehouse? Well, Jess, we reached out to Kate and this is what she had to say. Hey, Office Ladies podcast fans, it's me, Kate Flannery, Meredith from the Office. Yes, I did a lot of my own stunts. I kind of got the idea that as much physical comedy as I could do, I was going to do. So I said yes to a lot of my stunts, even though I know that there was a stunt double there that day.
你好，我被困住了。你好？我们收到了关于这一刻的粉丝提问。杰斯·摩尔写信说，凯特·弗兰纳里在仓库那个被删减的场景中自己做了特技吗？嗯，杰斯，我们联系了凯特，这就是她要说的。嘿，办公室女士播客粉丝们，是我，凯特·弗兰纳里，办公室里的梅雷迪思。是的，我做了很多自己的特技。我有一种想法，尽可能多地做身体喜剧，我都要做。所以我答应了很多特技，尽管我知道那天有一个特技替身在那里。
Debbie Evans, but they did not use her, happened several times. So I think the stunt people still got paid. And I never went to the hospital, so who cares, right? But yeah, we sort of perfected things. So by the time Meredith gets hit by the car in season four, we were really off to the races. So this episode, this stunt was kind of the beginnings of my bravery.
黛比·埃文斯，但他们没有用她，发生了好几次。所以我认为特技演员还是拿到了报酬。而且我从来没去过医院，所以谁在乎呢，对吧？但是的，我们算是完善了事情。所以当梅雷迪思在第四季被车撞时，我们真的开始比赛了。所以这一集，这个特技算是我的勇敢的开始。
So thanks for watching. She's fearless. She really is. That is insane. I mean, she is fearless. If you go and watch that deleted scene, truly a whole entire shelf full of stuff falls on her and you can't even see her.
所以谢谢观看。她是无畏的。她真的是。这太疯狂了。我的意思是，她是无畏的。如果你去看那个被删减的场景，真的整整一架子的东西砸在她身上，你甚至看不到她。
It's, she's, she's fearless. I would have been like Debbie I'm gonna need you, I'm gonna need you in. Debbie get on in here because I'm, there is no way I would have done that. No way. I am too much of a scaredy cat. You know what's interesting is that one of the things I really wanted to do on this show, I don't know why, I think I think I'm a badass driver. I'm probably not but I really wanted to do on the show, I don't know why, I think I think I'm a badass driver. I'm probably not, but I always wanted to do all my driving stunts.
它，她，她是无畏的。我会像黛比一样，我需要你，我需要你进来。黛比进来吧，因为我，我绝对不会那样做。没门。我太胆小了。你知道有趣的是，我在这个节目中真正想做的一件事，我不知道为什么，我想我想我是一个坏蛋司机。我可能不是，但我真的想在这个节目中做，我不知道为什么，我想我想我是一个坏蛋司机。我可能不是，但我总是想做我所有的驾驶特技。
And when they let me, like, because you know, Dwight and I have a few driving scenes, I would get really excited. Don't want to do those either. I like it when they hook it up to a rig and pull the car. I'm like, I don't want to drive this down the road while I'm acting. No one wants that.
当他们让我做的时候，就像，因为你知道，德怀特和我有一些驾驶场景，我会非常兴奋。我也不想做那些。我喜欢他们把它挂在装置上拉车的时候。我说，我不想在演戏的时候开车在路上跑。没人想要那样。
I've had to do that before. I'm always terrified. Well, one thing that did make it into the scene is this very odd moment of Daryl finding his iPod. And I want you to know that is not in the script. That was an improvisation by Craig on the day. He actually found an iPod deck and speaker somewhere back in the warehouse, and he just did this bit, and it made it into the show, and it is so funny to me. We got so much mail about it.
我以前不得不那样做。我总是很害怕。嗯，有一件事确实进入了场景，那就是达里尔找到他的iPod这个非常奇怪的时刻。我想让你知道那不在剧本里。那是克雷格当天即兴创作的。他实际上在仓库后面的某个地方找到了一个iPod底座和扬声器，他只是做了这个片段，它进入了节目，这对我来说太搞笑了。我们收到了很多关于它的邮件。
People were like, is there something I'm missing? Is there a deleted scene from a previous episode where Daryl loses his iPod? Is this product placement for iPod again? No, it was just this random funny bit. He does it with such like real enthusiasm. Well, we had to be there pretending like we were going through boxes, guys.
人们问，有什么我错过的吗？前一集有被删减的场景是达里尔丢了他的iPod吗？这是iPod的植入式广告吗？不，这只是这个随机有趣的片段。他做得非常有那种真正的热情。嗯，我们必须在那里假装我们在翻盒子，伙计们。
So we were really doing stuff, which you don't really see. It didn't really make it into the show, but I think that he legitimately opened up a box and that was in there and he got all excited. Yes, exactly. Well, I have a little Angela Roy moment that happens right at the same time. At 14 minutes, 44 seconds, you can see Angela starts to walk up to Roy and is about to go up to him.
所以我们真的在做事情，你没怎么看到。它没怎么进入节目，但我认为他合法地打开了一个盒子，里面有那个，他变得非常兴奋。是的，完全正确。嗯，我有一个小安吉拉·罗伊时刻，就在同一时间发生。在14分44秒，你可以看到安吉拉开始走向罗伊，正要走向他。
And then Daryl yells, I found an iPod dock. And I whip my head and I pivot the other way. Wow. You have to go and watch it. More of the untold Angela Roy story. And I'm wondering, I mean, what was meant to happen there? Like, it's not in the script, it's not in deleted scenes. But I'm sure I was given some direction maybe to go over
然后达里尔大喊，我找到了一个iPod底座。我猛地转头，转向另一个方向。哇。你必须去看看。更多未讲述的安吉拉·罗伊故事。我在想，我的意思是，那里本来应该发生什么？就像，它不在剧本里，不在被删减的场景里。但我肯定我得到了一些指导，也许去那边
and, you know, in the background sort of talk to Roy. But yeah, when Darryl yells, I turn around and go the other direction. It's a fun little catch. Well, then we see Pam is doing some inventory and Karen comes up to her and thanks her. She says, thank you so much for talking sense into Jim. Karen is so happy. Her relationship is back on. Everything's OK.
然后，你知道，在背景里和罗伊说话。但是的，当达里尔大喊时，我转过身朝另一个方向走。这是一个有趣的小发现。嗯，然后我们看到帕姆在做库存，凯伦走过来感谢她。她说，非常感谢你劝说吉姆。凯伦太高兴了。她的关系恢复了。一切都好了。
And then we cut to Pam just sobbing on a bench in the hallway. And Angela, I watched this scene, and it just brought tears to my eyes because I remember shooting it so clearly, so clearly. And we got a lot of, you know, I watched this scene and it just brought tears to my eyes because I remember shooting it so clearly, so clearly. And we got a lot of questions about it. So we got questions from Joe Salazar, Angie Letworth,
然后我们剪辑到帕姆在走廊的长椅上啜泣。安吉拉，我看了这个场景，它让我热泪盈眶，因为我记得拍摄它时非常清楚，非常清楚。而且我们有很多，你知道，我看了这个场景，它让我热泪盈眶，因为我记得拍摄它时非常清楚，非常清楚。而且我们有很多关于它的问题。所以我们收到了来自乔·萨拉查、安吉·莱特沃斯的问题，
Elisa Goldman, Jillian Riley, and Charlie Sparkenbaugh. They wanted to know, how was it filming that iconic Pam and Dwight scene when Pam is crying? Well, guys, this was like early on in the show. And whenever we had these really emotional scenes, like that parking lot scene with Jim and Pam, we would just kind of shut down everything. And I remember that we shut down the set
埃莉萨·戈德曼、吉莉安·莱利和查理·斯帕肯鲍。他们想知道，拍摄那个帕姆和德怀特哭泣的标志性场景是什么感觉？嗯，伙计们，这在节目早期。每当我们有这些非常情绪化的场景时，比如吉姆和帕姆在停车场的那个场景，我们就会关掉一切。我记得我们关掉了片场
and we took hours prepping and shooting this crying scene. It was really important to Greg that I really be crying. They did not want to put fake tears in my eyes. He wanted me to really go there. And this is a really big challenge for an actor. And so what they did was they made everything really quiet and no one talked to me for about a half hour. And I put on the saddest music I could find. And it was sad because it was personal to me, right? It was music that brought up memories of breakups,
我们花了几个小时准备和拍摄这个哭泣的场景。格雷格非常看重我真的在哭。他们不想在我的眼睛里放假眼泪。他想让我真的进入状态。这对演员来说是一个非常大的挑战。所以他们做的是让一切变得非常安静，半小时内没人跟我说话。我放了我能找到的最悲伤的音乐。这很悲伤，因为它对我来说是私人的，对吧？这是在我生命中不同时期，当我经历特别困难的时候听的音乐。所以它会引发很多情绪。我花了一周时间创建这个播放列表，因为我知道它会引发很多情绪。我坐着听，直到我哭出来。然后凯利，我们的第一助理导演，过来把耳机从我这里拿走，然后他们就开始拍摄了。
music that I listened to at different times in my life when I was having a particularly hard time. So it would bring up a lot of emotions. And I had spent the previous week creating this playlist because I knew that it would invoke a lot of emotion. And I sat and I listened to it until I was crying. And then Kelly, our first AD, came and took the headphones away from me, and then they started rolling.
我在人生中不同时期遇到特别困难时听的音乐。所以它会勾起很多情绪。我花了一周时间制作了这个播放列表，因为我知道它会引发很多情感。我坐着听，直到哭出来。然后我们的第一副导演凯利过来拿走了我的耳机，接着他们就开始拍摄了。
And that's how they were able to begin the scene with me crying. Because when you play a scene, Angela, and you have dialogue and you have connection with a person, a lot of times that will bring the emotion out of you, but it's really hard to start a scene in a full cry, because you would just have to get yourself there. No, that's so true. It's actually really hard because you're basically taking yourself emotionally from
这就是他们能够以我哭泣的场景作为开场的原因。因为当你演一场戏时，安吉拉，当你有了台词，并且与对方产生了连接，很多时候这会激发你的情绪，但要在一开始就进入大哭的状态真的很难，因为你必须得让自己进入那种情绪。不，确实如此。这真的很难，因为你基本上是在让自己从
zero to 60. And I had to do a crying scene in a show called Haters Back Off that was like something in the middle. And I remember they let me sort of just step away from set to get myself there. And once I was there, they started rolling. I took this acting class, and it was talking about emotional journeys. And the acting teacher encouraged us
零瞬间飙升到一百。我曾在一部叫《Haters Back Off》的剧中演过一场哭戏，那场戏大概是在中间部分。我记得他们让我稍微离开片场一会儿，好让自己进入状态。一旦我准备好了，他们就开始拍摄。我上过一个表演课，里面谈到了情感旅程。表演老师鼓励我们
to pick a song, one song, because sometimes on set, you don't have the luxury of being able to go listen. That really shows how much our show was taking care of you in that moment, I feel like. Yeah. Yeah. But sometimes you only have a few minutes to reset yourself emotionally and to get to that place.
选一首歌，只选一首歌，因为有时候在片场，你没有那种可以去听歌的奢侈条件。我觉得这真的体现了我们的剧组在那一刻是多么照顾你。是啊。是啊。但有时候你只有几分钟的时间来调整自己的情绪，让自己进入那种状态。
So we took, everyone picked one song and in your mind you sing that one song and by the end of that song, you should be in that emotional place. And it really worked for me. And I find for myself now, I'm older now, guys. I'm 49, and more life has happened to me. And it's easier for me to get to that place
所以我们每个人都选了一首歌，在心里唱那首歌，到歌结束时，你就应该进入那种情绪状态了。这对我真的很管用。我发现现在的我，我已经长大了，伙计们。我49岁了，经历的事情更多了。比起年轻时，现在我更容易进入那种状态
than when I was a younger actor. Yeah, same. But music is a big way to trigger it for me, and I think for a lot of actors. I've created musical soundtracks for a lot of things I've done. I had to do a play, and I had to start out the play in a rage. I had to start out very, very angry. And I couldn't find a song that exactly triggered my anger.
了。是啊，我也是。但音乐对我来说是触发情绪的重要方式，我想对很多演员来说也是如此。我为我做过的很多事情都创作过音乐原声带。我曾演过一部戏，开头需要表现出愤怒。我必须一上来就非常、非常生气。但我找不到一首能精准触发我愤怒的歌。
I had a song that would kind of amp me up, and then I realized I had some audio of an ex-boyfriend, ah, who I, like, really was pissed at still to this day. I found this audio tape, and I played his voice. And it made me so damn mad that I could, you can hear me right now just thinking about it. It made me so damn mad that I could just walk out on stage and start screaming at the other actor on stage because just his voice triggered me.
我有一首歌能让我兴奋起来，然后我意识到我有一些前男友的录音，啊，直到今天我对他依然非常生气。我找到了那盘录音带，播放了他的声音。这让我气得要命，你们现在光听我提起这件事就能听出来。这让我气得要命，以至于我可以直接走上舞台，对着另一位演员大喊大叫，因为仅仅是他的声音就触发了我的情绪。
Wow. So I think that music, something you can listen to, that works. Yeah. I think that goes, I mean, you guys listening, I know there are songs that take you right back to a moment in your life. That's the power and beauty of music, right? The song that would make me tear up by the end is a lefty Fizel song called That's the Way Love Goes. It's an old song. Some of you will know it. Some of you in this moment know that I'm 100 years old because it's a
哇。所以我认为音乐，那种你可以听的东西，确实有效。是啊。我觉得这很有道理，我是说，听众朋友们，我知道有些歌能让你瞬间回到生命中的某个时刻。这就是音乐的力量和美妙之处，对吧？那首能让我听到最后热泪盈眶的歌是Lefty Frizzell的《That's the Way Love Goes》。这是一首老歌。你们有些人会知道。你们中有些人现在肯定知道我有一百岁了，因为它是一首
really old song. Well one of the songs I was listening to to help make me cry for Pam was a Ben Fold song but I had a whole Pam soundtrack that I would listen to on my drive to work during season three when her and Jim were estranged and it was Nora Jones. Lady! She's just so soulful and wishing and a little lost. I remember you guys doing the scene. And I remember it from the filter of your BFF. And I remember you were really anxious about it. You really wanted to get it right.
非常老的歌。嗯，我为了演好帕姆而听的那些能帮我哭出来的歌里，有一首是本·福尔兹（Ben Folds）的歌，但我有一整套帕姆专属歌单，在第三季她和吉姆疏远期间，我开车去上班时都会听，那是诺拉·琼斯（Norah Jones）的歌。天哪！她的歌声太深情、太忧伤，还有点迷茫。我记得你们拍那场戏的时候。我记得我是从你最好的朋友的角度来看的。我记得你当时真的很焦虑。你真的很想把它演好。
You were doing all the prep. I remember when you guys went to do the scene that I left you alone. You know, you don't need your chatty five foot one. Ha la la la la la. I was like, I'm gonna give her all the space she needs. And rewatching it, Jenna, it made me tear up. It's so beautiful.
你做了所有的准备工作。我记得当你们去拍那场戏时，我让你一个人待着。你知道，你不需要你那个五英尺一英寸高、叽叽喳喳的朋友。啦啦啦啦啦。我当时想，我要给她所有她需要的空间。重看的时候，珍娜，我热泪盈眶。太美了。
And I think I see Rain as Dwight tearing up. But surely Dwight wouldn't tear up, but I think Rain, your friend, is tearing up watching you cry. Angela, it's making me get choked up when you say it because this is a little bit of a place where the line blurred between the Rain that you and I know and Dwight.
我想我看到了雷恩（Rainn）饰演的德怀特（Dwight）在流泪。但德怀特肯定不会流泪，但我认为雷恩，你的朋友，是在看着你哭的时候流泪的。安吉拉，你说这些话让我哽咽了，因为这在某种程度上模糊了我们认识的雷恩和德怀特之间的界限。
Rain simply couldn't do that scene without empathizing with Pam. Every time we did a take, he teared up when I cried harder. It was like Rainn Wilson, the man, was incapable of sitting next to a person in pain without feeling their pain. And this is the thing that we know about Rainn.
雷恩根本无法在不与帕姆共情的情况下完成那场戏。每次我们拍一条，当我哭得更厉害时，他也跟着流泪。就好像雷恩·威尔森（Rainn Wilson）本人，无法坐在一个痛苦的人身边而不去感受他们的痛苦。这就是我们所了解的雷恩。
It's the thing that we love about Rainn. And when I saw it in the scene, it just made me miss rain so much because that's who rain is to me on a personal level. Yeah. Yeah. I just saw rain. I just saw him and he's tearing up. And then he has to snap back to Dwight, you know, and say the line or, you know, PMSing pretty hard, right? Yeah. Yes. One of my favorite things he does in the scene as Dwight is he takes his jacket off and you're
这也是我们爱雷恩的地方。当我在戏里看到这一幕时，我真的很想念雷恩，因为这就是我在个人层面上所认识的雷恩。是啊。是啊。我刚才看到了雷恩。我看到了他，他在流泪。然后他必须立刻切换回德怀特的状态，你知道，说出那句台词，或者说，你知道，经前综合症很严重，对吧？是啊。是的。他在戏里作为德怀特做的我最喜欢的事情之一，就是他脱下外套，你
positive he's going to wrap it around Pam and he ties it around his waist so awkwardly. Yes, that was in the script. That's the other thing, all the little beats, all the moments, him putting his jacket around his waist, giving the handkerchief, awkwardly putting his arm around her shoulder, all of that is scripted, all those moments. It's just, it was a beautifully written scene and they gave us great time to figure it out and shoot it. I'm really proud of that scene.
肯定以为他要给帕姆披上，结果他却笨拙地把它系在了腰上。是的，剧本里就是这么写的。还有一件事，所有的小动作，所有的瞬间，他把外套系在腰上，递手帕，笨拙地把手臂搭在她的肩膀上，所有这些都是剧本写好的，所有这些瞬间。这真是一场写得非常优美的戏，他们给了我们充足的时间去琢磨和拍摄。我真的为那场戏感到自豪。
It's one of my favorites from the series that I got to do. I know. You just did it so well. Where are we now? Well, Jan has arrived. Oh, it's so awkward. Jan has arrived, and you could cut the tension. Even though we were acting, I remember
这是我在该系列中演过的最喜欢的戏之一。我知道。你演得太好了。我们现在到哪儿了？嗯，简（Jan）到了。哦，太尴尬了。简到了，空气中弥漫着紧张的气氛。尽管我们在演戏，但我记得
Melora has such a presence. And when she walked into that warehouse, it was like you could hear a pin drop. Even though we knew we were acting, it just was a powerful moment. Yes. And Michael's slow walk up the stairs was so good. So good.
梅洛拉（Melora）非常有气场。当她走进那个仓库时，简直是鸦雀无声。尽管我们知道是在演戏，但这依然是一个充满张力的时刻。是的。迈克尔（Michael）慢悠悠走上楼梯的样子太棒了。太棒了。
So good. And then Jenna, when they get back to Michael's office, what a power move. Jan is sitting in his seat. He has to sit across from her where the other employees would normally sit. It was so bad ass. I so loved it.
太棒了。然后珍娜，当他们回到迈克尔的办公室时，那真是权力博弈。简坐在了他的位置上。他不得不坐在她对面，也就是其他员工通常坐的地方。这太霸气了。我太喜欢了。
So now in this scene, you don't know what's going to happen. You're pretty sure that she knows about this picture and she has come to just lay into Michael about sending out this photo. But she's either unaware of the photo or she doesn't care because she tells Michael this amazing speech. It's so amazing. It's so good.
所以现在在这场戏里，你不知道会发生什么。你很确定她知道这张照片的事，她来这里就是为了因为发照片的事狠狠教训迈克尔一顿。但她要么是不知道照片的事，要么就是不在乎，因为她对迈克尔说了这番惊人的演讲。太惊人了。太棒了。
She says her therapist thinks she has self-destructive tendencies and she should just lean into them. Let's try that for a change. Let's just go with the destruction. I love it. She says, in this past year, I have been through a divorce, an identity theft, an identity theft. She's like, my ex-husband, you know, can't or won't share his feelings with me. And then she says, maybe she will find happiness by
她说她的治疗师认为她有自我毁灭倾向，她应该顺从这种倾向。让我们换个方式试试。让我们顺从这种毁灭吧。我喜欢。她说，在过去的一年里，我经历了一场离婚，一次身份盗窃，一次身份盗窃。她说，我的前夫，你知道，不能或者不愿与我分享他的感受。然后她说，也许她会通过
lowering her expectations and following her instinct to be with Michael. Everything in Melora's performance is perfection and then it is mirrored by Steve's perfect reactions to everything she's saying. He is confused, he isn't sure if he can be happy, he's clearly like afraid to react. Yeah he's frozen because he's like she's breaking up with me. Wait she's not? Which she likes me. Oh but she's leaving me. Who's this therapist? What's happening? It's like, all of those things are happening. And then, you know, she grabs him
降低期望并追随她想和迈克尔在一起的直觉来找到幸福。梅洛拉的表演堪称完美，而史蒂夫（Steve）对她所说的一切做出的完美反应与之相映成趣。他很困惑，他不确定自己是否能幸福，他显然很害怕做出反应。是啊，他僵住了，因为他觉得她在跟我分手。等等，她没有？她喜欢我。哦，但她要离开我。这个治疗师是谁？发生了什么？就像是，所有这些念头都在他脑海里闪过。然后，你知道，她抓住他
and gives him a big sloppy kiss. I wrote on my card, Jan, hashtag DGAF. What's DGAF? Don't give a f**k. Oh, because she knows the camera crew is there. She is clearly over it. She's like, I'm going to lean into this, just like my doctor said.
给了他一个又大又湿的吻。我在我的卡片上写道，简，标签：DGAF。DGAF是什么？就是“老子不在乎”（Don't give a f**k）。哦，因为她知道摄制组在场。她显然已经不在乎了。她就像是，我要顺从这一点，就像我医生说的那样。
She says, meet me back at your condo in 15 minutes. And then it's my favorite moment. I mean, well, there's many favorite moments, but this is one of my favorite moments. He is stunned and he looks at her and says, you complete me like from Jerry Maguire, like that scene in the elevator. He's like, you complete me. And she looks at him and pauses.
她说，15分钟后在你的公寓见。然后就是我最喜欢的时刻。我是说，嗯，有很多喜欢的时刻，但这绝对是我最喜欢的时刻之一。他惊呆了，看着她说，你完整了我（You complete me），就像《甜心先生》（Jerry Maguire）里电梯里的那场戏一样。他说，你完整了我。她看着他，停顿了一下。
It's such a such a wonderful pause. And she goes, oh, God. All of that was scripted, Angela. It's so good. It says that he says that line, and then it says, Jan pauses and then sighs. But she's like, still gonna meet him at his apartment. Yeah, that oh, God is like,
那是一个非常、非常美妙的停顿。然后她说，哦，天哪。所有这些都是剧本写好的，安吉拉。太棒了。剧本写着他说那句台词，然后写着简停顿了一下，然后叹了口气。但她还是打算去他的公寓见他。是啊，那个“哦，天哪”就像是，
well, I'm in it now. Lady, we got a fan question about this scene that so intrigued me. Listen to this. This is from Nilly. Nilly said, Daniel Levinson and Roger Gould are adult developmental psychologists who have contributed massively to the field,
好吧，我现在陷进去了。女士们，我们收到了一个关于这场戏的粉丝提问，非常吸引我。听听这个。这是来自Nilly的。Nilly说，丹尼尔·莱文森（Daniel Levinson）和罗杰·古尔德（Roger Gould）是成人发展心理学家，他们为该领域做出了巨大贡献，
including the study and definition of the midlife crisis. Is Jan Levinson-Gould's name a reference to the fact that she is the epitome of a midlife crisis or is it just a coincidence? That is an amazing catch. I think it's a coincidence because I don't think they knew that the character of Jan was going to become what she was when we started. So when they named her Jan Levinson Gould, they were not aware that she was going to spin out and go
包括对中年危机的研究和定义。简·莱文森-古尔德（Jan Levinson-Gould）的名字是否暗示了她是中年危机的缩影，还是仅仅是个巧合？这是一个了不起的发现。我认为这只是个巧合，因为我不认为我们在开始时就知道简这个角色会变成后来那样。所以当他们给她起名简·莱文森-古尔德时，他们并不知道她会失控并走上
down this road with Michael yet. That happened over time. But I will tell you that I appreciate this fan letter because it sent me down a fabulous two-hour rabbit hole where I googled Dr. Roger Gould adult development theory. Fascinating. I'd like you to know that you can also get a book called The Seasons of a Man's Life by Dr. Daniel Levinson. But all of their work was combined into a wonderful book by Gail Sheehy. She's a feminist journalist and she wrote Passages, Predictable Crises
这条与迈克尔纠缠不清的道路。那是随着时间推移发生的。但我得说，我很感谢这封粉丝来信，因为它让我陷入了一个美妙的两小时“兔子洞”，我谷歌搜索了罗杰·古尔德博士的成人发展理论。太迷人了。我想让你们知道，你们还可以买到一本丹尼尔·莱文森博士写的《男人的一生》（The Seasons of a Man's Life）。但他们所有的研究都被盖尔·希伊（Gail Sheehy）整合进了一本精彩的书里。她是一位女权主义记者，她写了《人生转折点：成年期的可预测危机》（Passages, Predictable Crises
of Adult Life. Did I buy all these books and I'm waiting for them? Maybe I did, Nilly. She's a feminist journalist and she wrote passages predictable crises of adult life Did I buy all these books and I'm waiting for them. Maybe I did Nilly. Maybe I did I'll report back. But guys if you want to go on the journey with me, you can Google it all. It was really awesome Jenna I love this so much because you and I do our prep separately. So I don't know the rabbit holes You going down. You're doing that and I spent half an hour looking up different flavors of jelly beans. It's all valid, lady. It's all good. And all important. It's all important. Well, you know, so we go back to the luau. It's not going great. People look like they're having a pretty lame time and there's a scene between Roy and Pam and he kind of cheers her up. Yeah yeah Roy says remember how we were deciding where to go on the honeymoon you wanted Hawaii I wanted Mexico well I was right so I
of Adult Life）。我是不是买了所有这些书，现在正等着它们送达？也许吧，Nilly。她是一位女权主义记者，她写了《人生转折点：成年期的可预测危机》。我是不是买了所有这些书，现在正等着它们送达？也许吧，Nilly。也许吧，我会回来汇报的。但伙计们，如果你想和我一起踏上这段旅程，你可以去谷歌搜索一下。这真的很棒。珍娜，我太喜欢这个了，因为你和我都是分开做准备工作的。所以我不知道你钻进了什么“兔子洞”。你在做这些，而我花了半小时研究不同口味的软糖豆。这都很有意义，女士。这都很好。而且都很重要。都很重要。好吧，你知道，我们回到卢奥派对（Luau）。情况不太好。人们看起来玩得很无聊，罗伊（Roy）和帕姆（Pam）之间有一场戏，他算是让她振作起来了。是啊，是啊，罗伊说，还记得我们当时在决定去哪里度蜜月吗？你想要夏威夷，我想要墨西哥，嗯，我是对的，所以我
think he's sort of saying that Mexico would be better than Hawaii because this Luel's lame I don't track his, but Pam laughs and I think she really needed that laugh. Yeah, this was the first moment where we show that like Pam is being comforted by Roy. So all along we've been seeing Roy try to make these gestures reaching out to her and this one lands. And this was kind of going to maybe put Pam and Roy back on track. Well before we wrap up Back From Vacation, Jenna, I have one deleted scene. It's a Michael talking head and I have to share it with you because it really sums up Michael's state of mind as he comes back from Jamaica. Alright, I gotta hear this. What is it?
想他大概是想说墨西哥会比夏威夷好，因为这个卢奥派对太无聊了。我不明白他的逻辑，但帕姆笑了，我觉得她真的很需要那个笑容。是啊，这是我们第一次展示帕姆被罗伊安慰的时刻。所以一直以来，我们都在看罗伊试图做出这些姿态来接近她，而这一次奏效了。这可能让帕姆和罗伊的关系重回正轨。好吧，在结束《度假归来》（Back From Vacation）这一集之前，珍娜，我有一个删减片段。这是一个迈克尔的采访片段，我必须和你分享，因为它真的总结了迈克尔从牙买加回来后的心态。好吧，我一定要听听。是什么？
So Michael is driving in his car to work. It's his first day back to work from Jamaica, driving in his car, talking head. He says, you know how they say take a chill pill? In Jamaica, I took one. Guy on the beach sold it to me for $40. And after I finished vomiting, I was more relaxed than I've ever been. I lost six pounds too. And that's how I want every day to be. Yeah. He wants to take
所以迈克尔开车去上班。这是他从牙买加回来上班的第一天，开车，采访片段。他说，你知道人们常说“吃颗冷静丸”（take a chill pill）吗？在牙买加，我吃了一颗。海滩上的一个家伙以40美元的价格卖给我的。在我吐完之后，我感到前所未有的放松。我还瘦了六磅。这就是我希望每天的样子。是啊。他想吃
a pill, vomit his brains out, then be relaxed, and then have a pina colada at three o'clock. Yeah. have a pina colada at three o'clock. Yeah. Amazing. Amazing. Well, guys, that was back from vacation. Yes, thank you so much for sending in your questions. And a big thank you to Kim Ferry. You can find her on Instagram at hairfairy.kim.
一颗药，吐个天翻地覆，然后变得放松，然后在三点钟喝一杯椰林飘香（pina colada）。是啊。在三点钟喝一杯椰林飘香。是啊。太棒了。太棒了。好吧，伙计们，这就是《度假归来》。是的，非常感谢你们寄来的问题。还要特别感谢金·费里（Kim Ferry）。你们可以在Instagram上关注她，账号是hairfairy.kim。
That's H-A-I-R-F-E-R-R-Y.kim. She posts so many fun behind the scenes things from all the projects she's worked on, including the office. And Kate Flannery, thank you so much for your audio clip. I asked Kate, was there anything I could share? And she said, will you tell them all that I'm just so tickled that I, Meredith Palmer has a Funko pop? I love that. You can see what Kate's up to at The Real Kate Flannery on Instagram.
那是H-A-I-R-F-E-R-R-Y.kim。她发布了很多她参与过的所有项目（包括《办公室》）的幕后趣事。还有凯特·弗兰纳里（Kate Flannery），非常感谢你的音频片段。我问凯特，有什么我可以分享的吗？她说，你能告诉大家，我真的很高兴我，梅雷迪思·帕尔默（Meredith Palmer）有一个Funko Pop玩偶吗？我喜欢这个。你们可以在Instagram上通过The Real Kate Flannery查看凯特的动态。
And also thank you to Justin Spitzer and of course, Kintopedia for helping us answer all those fan questions. Thanks guys. Yes, and Phil Shea. I reach out to these guys all the time and they always come through for me. We couldn't do the podcast without them, just like we couldn't make the show without them. That's right.
还要感谢贾斯汀·斯皮策（Justin Spitzer），当然还有Kintopedia帮助我们回答了所有这些粉丝提问。谢谢你们，伙计们。是的，还有菲尔·谢（Phil Shea）。我一直联系这些人，他们总是能帮我解决问题。没有他们，我们就做不成这个播客，就像没有他们，我们就拍不成这部剧一样。没错。
And you guys, and Sam, and Cody. Love you all. Have a great week and we'll see you next time. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwolf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jorkins and our audio engineer and associate producer is Molly Nugent.
还有你们，还有萨姆（Sam），还有科迪（Cody）。爱你们所有人。祝大家度过愉快的一周，我们下次见。感谢收听《办公室女士的第二杯》（Office Ladies' Second Drink）。本集最初是与Earwolf合作制作的。《办公室女士》由Odyssey呈现，由珍娜·费舍尔（Jenna Fisher）和安吉拉·金赛（Angela Kinsey）制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·乔金斯（Cassie Jorkins），我们的音频工程师和助理制片人是莫莉·纽金特（Molly Nugent）。
Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. Music There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Odyssey的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯（Leah Reese Dennis）。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨（Bill Schultz）混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿（Creed Bratton）的《Rubber Tree》。音乐 这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。